learn the 50 most popular linux commands
from colt steel
all these commands work on linux mac os
and any other place you have a unix
environment colt is an extremely popular
instructor and for good reason he has a
knack for teaching complex topics in a
way that beginners can understand hey
everyone my name is colt steele and
today we are going to learn a ton about
the command line and different linux
commands i'm a developer well honestly
more of a teacher who happens to write
code
i teach in-person web development i've
run boot camps in san francisco i now do
a lot of online teaching and i have a
boot camp i created with springboard if
you want to learn more you can find a
link in the description and this
is a picture of one of my cats i
actually have to take her to the vet
like in five minutes really her tail is
just drooping down for no reason i was
gonna take her sooner but you know i had
to make this for you
let's hope she survives before i say
anything else i want to give a big
thanks to flavio copez i think i
actually only know him as flavio maybe
it's pronounced copes but i'm pretty
sure it's not anyway uh he generously
allowed me to use his linux commands
handbook there's a link in the
description of course very detailed and
thorough handbook
if you're not familiar with his work he
puts out handbooks and tutorials on all
sorts of topics so this is just one of
many different handbooks
anyway he is allowing me to use his
handbook along with some of the
materials i've created to create this
mutant super course on youtube
so we are going to cover 50 actually i
think it's a little more than 50
commands
that are useful obviously to varying
degrees some of them you'll use every
single day
as a developer for example
and then some of them
you may never use except in an emergency
situation once a year but i'm going to
cover a bunch of them they're not really
in a particular order especially towards
the end of the course but at the
beginning i ended up deciding that
instead of just 50 random commands in
any order i wanted to make something for
uh anybody so if you're a beginner you
can start at the beginning and we'll go
through the basics navigation working
with the basic commands and options and
making folders and files and so on but
then after about this point
things really open up and you can jump
around to whatever commands you'd like
and of course if you're someone who
already has some terminal experience
some of these commands are familiar to
you just hop around take a look at the
description there are time stamps and
just click on whatever command you're
not really comfortable with or you've
never heard of
there's probably something here for you
but if you're a beginner i definitely
would recommend starting at the
beginning so aside from these commands
which there's a lot here and this is a
pretty long video i also cover some
concepts that are pretty important so
the very basics things like why even
learn this stuff if you're not a linux
user you're on a mac you're on windows
why do you need to know linux commands
do you need to know them the answer is
probably yes if you're trying to break
into web development programming coding
engineering any sort of techie industry
then we'll talk about things like unix
and gnu and linux and unix-like and true
unix what is all that uh what is a shell
what is bash z-shell
kernel terminology stuff so that's all
coming up of course there's time stamps
if you want to skip around if you don't
care about that stuff and then
installation so if you're on a mac you
don't really have to do anything if you
already have linux installed you don't
really have to do anything either
and if you're on windows well we have to
jump through some hoops the good news is
fewer hoops than we had to jump through
a couple months or years ago so i'm
going to show you how to install
something called windows subsystem for
linux
then we'll also talk about concepts like
command structure and arguments and
options working with man pages folder
structure of linux redirecting standard
output appending standard outputs tilde
expansion history expansion path name
expansion curly brace expansion
and permissions so we're going to end
with permission is a pretty big chunk
honestly at the end of this course it's
devoted to just these two commands and
understanding how to read and manipulate
permissions on linux so there's a lot
here there's some introductory
conceptual stuff in terminology
installation and then we start from the
basics so you could know nothing about
the terminal never have entered a
command in your life start at the
beginning and don't skip around or if
you feel confident or you know some of
this stuff jump around use the time
stamps they are there for you all right
so let's start with a quick discussion
around why this matters why should you
learn these commands uh yes at times it
might seem like you're you know doing
stuff straight out of a 1980s hacker
movie um and we're
far more advanced and things have
improved so much why do we still have to
use text commands well there's a bunch
of reasons including the fact that
you can just do a lot more from the
terminal using these commands we're
going to learn you'll have more control
greater access you can do things you
just cannot do otherwise there's just no
way around that if you want to start a
server manage different processes
interact with databases all sorts of
things alter permissions you need to
know terminal commands to do that
another reason it's faster at least once
you get past the basic hurdles you learn
the commands you get used to them you
can do things way faster we can make
10 000 files in a single line i can make
10 000 empty files all with different
names doing that graphically with my
mouse or file new save file new save
would take hours now that's just a sort
of far-fetched example but in general we
can do things much faster the one
problem is that when you're learning
it's going to be much slower i kind of
already hinted at this one but we can
actually automate things we can speed up
repetitive processes we can save
ourselves a lot of time
another reason it's available everywhere
so if you learn these commands
you'll be able to work on any linux
distribution you'll be able to then
switch over to a mac if needed and use
the commands on a mac now on windows yes
it's a little bit different so it's not
technically available everywhere but
these commands we're going to learn are
pretty standard across any sort of
developer software engineer career which
leads me to the next point it's
essentially a requirement if you want to
be a web developer data scientist devops
engineer sys admin security admin
machine learning engineer ai engineer
whatever
any type of coding related career you
are probably going to need to use the
command line you will have tools that
only exist on the command line that
you'll need to be able to use so for a
lot of people that's the only reason
that really matters you just need it if
you want to get a job it's just part of
the expected skill set also a lot of
cloud computing programs or services
don't even have a graphical user
interface you just have to do things via
a command line and again high-paying
jobs lots of careers lots of roles that
you'll need to at least know the basics
of working with terminal commands so the
next topic i'd like to quickly discuss
is a little bit of context around
operating systems and why these commands
will work on linux and on mac by default
but they're not going to work on a
windows machine at least not out of the
box so uh there's quite a lot of
complicated history uh and
and uh drama
around different operating systems
things being open source versus closed
source and competition
and copying each other
it's quite dramatic but the general gist
that you need to understand is that over
the years since the very early days of
computing well maybe not the super
earliest days but we're going back to
the 70s here this is a timeline that
shows
a very detailed timeline that shows
operating systems and how they're
connected
anyway in the 1970s there was something
called unix you can see it here
and just take a look at all of these
lines this whole family of operating
systems that it spawned
so there's lots and lots of them
everything in red here is considered in
some way related uh or indebted to
unix
so that includes things like linux
so in this course i'll be using ubuntu
which you can see here it is a
distribution of linux but there's many
many others things like android chrome
os but also other uh more common linux
distributions like fedora or red hats
anyway all this linux stuff is
descendant from unix all the way back
here in the 70s now we also will see
somewhere in here all the different mac
operating systems here we are
so mac os x we've got ios the apple tv
os audio os
watch os all these different apple
products all the apple operating systems
also related to unix
but then our good friend windows
somewhere down here it's not an it's not
even in the same red color
just to show how it is completely
different it is in green this world of
windows so windows windows vista windows
xp
windows mobile windows phone
xbox os all that stuff is over here it's
just kind of on its own
it is not related it's not
you know a descendant of that original
unix operating system from way back in
the 70s now the reason this matters
is that
all of these guys in red up here
they tend to share the same commands
unix was this operating system developed
in the mid 60s at bell labs really cool
time lots of innovation going on
uh but what matters to us today 50 plus
years later is that lots of those
innovations lots of those new ideas and
the specific commands the actual
interfaces the way a file system was
structured all of that carries over
today yes it's changed it's been
expanded
but it is present in all of those red
descendants of unix unfortunately for
our windows users those commands
don't exist natively on windows
windows has its own set of commands its
own default shell its own way of doing
things so i'm going to talk about how we
can get these unix commands to work
on windows but just so you understand
why this is a problem in the first place
it just has to do with the history there
are so many of these os's over the years
inspired by
and descended from the original unix os
including linux and mac os
but not windows
lonely windows over here alright so now
we have a basic understanding of the
fact that
of today's operating systems there's
really those two groups everything
descended from microsoft and then kind
of everything else that is in some form
some way related to unix now that's a
vast simplification
but again we're just talking about
popular operating systems so you know
linux chrome mac os all these things
come from unix
now let's talk about linux and unix and
all that stuff in a little bit more
detail so that you understand what
exactly linux is why it exists so this
is a diagram from wikipedia
that shows the history going back to
1969 early unix versions
and how it spawned all the you know
other
operating systems that are connected to
it
now what you'll see
is that there are three colors red is
closed source or pink
and that means the code is completely
closed off you can't edit it you can't
view it you're not allowed to even try
to tweak it
then we have open source which you may
be familiar with that term the code is
openly
viewable you can change it tweak it make
your own versions try things out
and then there's in yellow this mixed
shared source type of
operating systems so what you'll see
here is that early on unix and a lot of
other operating systems in the early
days were mixed or shared source but
then there was a plethora of closed
source operating systems uh that were
very walled off and you were not allowed
to do anything with that code you were
not allowed to view edit tweak and so on
and that led to the rise of something
called the free software movement free
in this context does not mean no money
free
beer it instead means free in the
context of freedom free speech
so this software movement was all about
uh the the idea that you should be able
to collaborate you should be able to
edit code view source code run copy
distribute study change and improve
software should not be walled off
and the leader of this movement was this
guy named richard stallman so he began
work on something that ended up being
called gnu gnu
that was his own free software
alternative to unix so he wanted to make
a full operating system that had
everything that normally came with unix
but it was going to be completely free
again free meaning you could tweak it
and edit it do whatever you want to it
and see the source code now that's a
huge undertaking creating an operating
system
and at the same time this other
developer named linus torvalds or linus
torvalds
was working on something called a kernel
and we'll talk about what that is in a
moment
but this kernel he was working on he
called it linux and a kernel is a very
complicated and critical part of an
operating system it is the thing that
basically sits between the hardware and
the software and it facilitates the
interactions between different pieces of
software and then the actual the
physical hardware of the computer
so
what happened is that richard stallman
was working on the gnu project trying to
build a full operating system well he
didn't have a kernel but at the same
time linus torvalds was working on a
kernel and torvalds ended up merging his
kernel with the existing
new components from richard stallman to
create this whole operating system just
a quick note so i don't get any negative
comments here
there is a bit of controversy over the
name of the resulting operating system a
lot of people
most people have heard of linux
fewer people have heard of gnu the term
linux
often people use it to refer to the
entire resulting system when in reality
uh the linux kernel was just one piece
that was added on to some existing
components but what matters for us here
if we go way back to this slide
over here
is that what we see is a bunch of closed
source mix source
operating systems all over here and then
this thing called linux pops up right
there around 1991 in green it's open
source now there's not a direct line as
you can see going back to any of these
what are called true unix operating
systems and the reason for that uh is
yet another piece of history there is a
global consortium called the open group
they own the trademark for unix
in order for you to call your operating
system unix if you make an os and you
want it to be certified you have to pay
a lot of money you have to go through a
bunch of testing you have to comply with
a bunch of regulations and standards and
it's a complicated process and there's
money involved it's not very
free free software so we have another
term there's true unix you've been
certified as a true unix operating
system
and then we have unix-like operating
systems which are compatible with the
unix standards they implement things
correctly but they haven't been
certified as actually true unix
and this is often because of financial
considerations or ethical objections to
the existence of the idea of true unix
so what we see on this slide here is
linux enters the picture it is not
considered true unix but rather it's
considered unix-like
remember that linux itself is just a
kernel which is very very important it's
again that piece of the operating system
that connects the hardware to the
software so that's what linux is really
it's the kernel but when we talk about
things like ubuntu what ubuntu is is a
linux distribution it is one of many
many distributions out there there's
nearly a thousand last time i checked uh
you may have heard of fedora slackware
ubuntu that's what i'll be using
and what each distribution is it's it's
the linux kernel it's some gnu tools
documentation a package manager a
desktop environment a window management
system a whole bunch of other things
combined together to form a full
operating system
so to recap all of that
there are tons and tons of operating
systems on this chart you can see some
are open source some are closed source
some are mixed source uh some of them
are considered true unix they've paid
they've been certified by this
foundation or this consortium to be true
unix but then over here we have linux
linux is fully open source and whether
you call it linux or linux gnu or gnu
linux
it is a
unix-like operating system that conforms
to all these standards these operating
systems do we can use the same commands
things are structured the same way there
are subtle differences but it doesn't
really matter everything on this chart
here they're all part of this greater
unix family or unix inspired family now
we have one last piece of terminology
and history and all that stuff to get
out of the way before we move on to
actually running commands we need to
talk about the term shell so you may
have heard of this before
if you're on windows you may have heard
of powershell or you may have heard of
bash or z shell or you maybe never have
heard of them but there's this concept
of something called a shell
what the shell is is a very very
important piece of software that is
going to expose the operating system
itself to human users or to other
programs so it is the thing that takes
our commands and hands them over to the
operating system to actually perform and
the term shell comes from the fact that
it's the outer layer around the
operating system like the shell around
an oyster so there's this other term
terminal way back in the day a terminal
used to be an actual piece of hardware
it would have a screen and it was a
physical device with a keyboard you'd go
over and you'd enter your commands into
the terminal
today terminal is just a piece of
software it's an application there's
many different terminal applications
it's the place we go to type our
commands when we hit enter there's some
shell that we are using in that terminal
window uh by default on ubuntu and most
linux distributions that shell is called
bash on macs these days the shell is
called z shell zsh another very popular
shell is fish there are many other
shells out there though
and again their job is to take commands
that we provide
or other applications humans or
applications provide and then give them
over to the operating system and make
sense of it all so again i'll be using
bash that's the default shell that comes
with the boom 2 but if you're on a mac
i'll talk about installation and you'll
see that fortunately z shell is very
very similar and the commands are still
going to work so it's not a big deal at
all but it's good to know that there are
different shells
and then the job of that shell is to
take those commands and pass them over
to the operating system and as i
mentioned bash is the most popular shell
out there uh especially on linux based
systems uh it is the most common default
shell
and the name if you're wondering it
comes from born again shell
and it really doesn't matter but it's
this reference to this guy steven bourne
who created a different shell called sh
a direct ancestor of bash so there's sh
and then born again sh
and again bash will run on pretty much
every version of unix or unix-like
systems so it does run on macs it runs
on you know any linux distribution any
of the unix operating systems that you
can see on that massive chart next up
let's talk about setup and installing
things if needed so that you can run
these commands
so right now we're looking at a linux
distribution this is ubuntu this is the
linux distribution i'll be using
throughout the course
if you already have linux if you have
some version of it some distribution
just use that it's going to be very very
similar all that you need to know is
there's a
built-in terminal application if i just
search for terminal
i'm going to be running my commands in
here probably change the color
and this is where i'll type my commands
so if you are on a mac you do not need
to go and install ubuntu and a virtual
machine that's actually how i'm running
this i'm still on my mac here but i'm
running it in a virtual machine you can
do that but
unless you have a really good reason to
i would just stick with what you know
because the commands that i'm going to
show you will work on a mac
all right so this is just for users who
already have ubuntu here's the terminal
app you just search for it and we'll run
our commands there
now if you are a mac user
remember it's part of this unix family
unix-like
operating systems all the commands i'm
going to show you will work on the mac
all you need to do is search for
terminal
and it will probably look a bit
different than this but you will have a
terminal where you can run the same
commands i show you so over here on
ubuntu when i show the psax ww command
it works you don't need to run this by
the way but over here on my mac same
thing p s a x w w
it also works and it will actually learn
what this is but it gives me a bunch of
stuff all right windows users it's your
turn let's talk about installation and
the steps we need to go through in order
to run linux
so remember the problem here is that on
windows
we just don't have access to the same
commands they're implemented differently
windows is not part of this unix family
this unix like family of operating
systems so this means that a lot of the
commands you'll learn
in this video and that developers use
every single day
are not going to work on windows or
they'll work differently or they'll
partially work now windows has its own
set of commands and as you could live in
that world exclusively it's just a
different world so if you want to use a
lot of the common developer tools and
you know you're watching this video you
probably already know what you want to
do
we need to get some way of running linux
commands on windows the way that we do
this is really two options there used to
only be one
we used to have to have a virtual
machine it's a pain to install uh it's
totally isolated from your actual
windows
operating system
and it can be slow can have a lot of
overhead
now instead we have a really cool fancy
option called wsl windows subsystem for
linux this is actually put out by
microsoft
and it allows us to run a linux
environment directly on windows or
inside of windows so it's not isolated
it's not a virtual machine it actually
works directly inside of windows
it's just a command line version of of
linux to be clear so we're not going to
have a separate desktop you're not going
to have you know all the apps and stuff
that i have on ubuntu but that's kind of
the point you can still be a windows
user and have linux commands from the
command line
so it's really really cool it's updated
pretty frequently it's still under
active development and the really good
news is that it's a lot easier to
install these days than it used to be
you do need to make sure you have
windows 10 version 2004 with build
number 19041 or higher or windows 11 in
order to use the simplified installation
instructions otherwise uh you can follow
i would recommend going to this webpage
anyway
docs.microsoft.com look for wsl
because this does change but if you have
an older version you can still install
wsl you just have different instructions
but if you have
the appropriate build number or higher
all we need to do is from the app called
powershell which i have open right now
you can just search powershell
okay this opens up this terminal where i
can you can see ps by the way i'm using
powershell
i can type commands in here and it tells
me in that case i don't know what the
heck you're talking about
but the command we want to run is wsl
dash dash install so let's try it wsl
dash dash
install
the requested operation requires
elevation so what this is telling me is
that i need to have admin privileges or
permissions to do that so why is that
happening well i need to run powershell
as an administrator so i'm going to
search again for powershell powershell
but i'm going to click on run as
administrator here
all right and that opens me up a new
window it says administrator windows
powershell and we try again wsl dash
dash install
whoops
and it might take a little while
so i'll be back when hopefully this
finishes successfully
and if not i guess he'll watch me debug
it
oh check it out already we can see it's
downloading ubuntu so that's the default
linux distribution it uses when i first
installed wsl a year or two ago for a
different course uh you actually had to
go and download your linux distribution
separately you had to go download wsl
separately you had to then connect the
two and point it to the particular
installation and it was just a huge pain
but now
hopefully super easy take a look it says
the requested operation is successful
that's always good changes won't be
effective until the system is rebooted
so let's reboot
okay so once that finishes up i
restarted uh i now have actually when i
restarted it automatically opened up
ubuntu which is now installed it wasn't
even a thing before
now i have an app i can run called
ubuntu it opens up right now at least
this
terminal that i can see here and it
tells me you know i had to install for a
few minutes
and then it wants me to set up a default
user account and this username that i
set up does not have to match my windows
username but whatever you do you know
you want to remember what you put in
here so this is going to be for our
ubuntu part of this machine i'm going to
make my username colt
and then a password
and you'll want to remember that
password you're not going to see what
you're typing i'll hit enter and then
retype it again
you can change that password later i'll
actually show you a command you can use
to change that password
and there we are i now have linux i'm
running ubuntu on my windows machine so
the commands will learn things like pwd
and who am i
just to show a couple simple ones or
p-s-a-x-w-w
there are lots and lots of commands
we're going to cover and they now will
work these commands are running on
windows now there is some additional
setup you can go through
if you go to the installation
documentation they recommend on windows
that you whoops this is the wrong page
here they recommend that after you set
up your linux user info which we just
did
that you can also install an app called
windows terminal
and windows terminal is uh remember a
terminal is just an application that can
run different shelves and
it can sort of be a jack of all trades
we can use windows terminal as our
terminal it's just a more sort of fancy
better features more customizable
terminal application so you do not need
to do this but if you want to
you can install the windows terminal app
and you can make it look all nice and
pretty
and run ubuntu from inside windows
terminal rather than the default
terminal that comes with ubuntu so one
more time perfectly serviceable just to
use this terminal but if you want to get
windows terminal if you're serious about
you know mastering all this stuff and
working
as a developer or some other you know
you want to use the terminal day in and
day out windows terminal is just the
better option it has more features so
i'm going to install it i'm going to
download it just from windows website or
microsoft's website now that it finished
i'll click launch
and remember a terminal is just
like a piece of software that can
connect or interact with different
shells so right now it opened up with
powershell which is not what we want to
use in this course
first of all let's see if i can just
make this
larger font for you there we go okay
it's a little bit larger now so as you
can see it's using powershell but i can
click this little drop down arrow here
and switch over to instead use ubuntu
so now i'm in ubuntu you can see my
prompt changes here it has my username
in there
you can customize the appearance and all
of that so if we go to settings
you know you can go down to ubuntu you
can set up a different appearance font
size
but what you can also do is set the
default profile to be ubuntu and if we
save that
it now means when i make a new window if
i just do plus
it is ubuntu you can see my little linux
penguin that's the logo there and we're
now up and running with windows terminal
there's a lot you can do to customize it
but that's not really the point of this
course so now you have it run your
commands here when you see me run them
in ubuntu uh run them here okie dokie
that should hopefully wrap up
installation whether you are actually
running linux like
like i am right now ubuntu this is the
desktop version i have the terminal open
i will be running my commands right here
but if you're not maybe you're using a
mac
so here's my mac i've got my terminal
open right here i'll run commands inside
the terminal application here they'll
work just the same
and then finally if you're on windows
hopefully you installed wsl so here we
are i'm running this is windows terminal
i make sure i'm running ubuntu here
i run my commands right here so
whichever one you're on just make sure
you know where you're going to be
running those commands if you're on
windows make sure it's not powershell
because you'll run into problems we want
to make sure we are running ubuntu so
that our unix commands will work
otherwise they won't
yes by the way all three of these are on
one computer right now i've got linux
windows and my mac
okay let's get started okay so now that
we hopefully have everything installed
correctly we can go ahead and get
started now before we do the first thing
i just want to make clear is that for
the most part there's no order to the
commands in this video it's a bunch of
commands and they're useful and most of
them don't really have to do with one
another or depend on each other but
early on right now i'm going to go
through some of the very basic commands
and there is a logical order to how i'm
going to teach them all that is to say
if you're a complete beginner stay right
here and we'll go through the basics in
order but if you have experience if you
know the basics of ls and
man and cd and pwd you may want to skip
ahead so check out the time stamps in
the description below and click on
whatever command looks interesting or
you'd like to learn more about but if
you are new stick with me let's go ahead
and get started all right so before we
talk about commands let's talk about not
commands in my prompt
if i start typing really anything and i
hit enter
the shell is going to try and process
that and figure out what command i'm
referring to but i'm not referring to
any valid command so i get a message
that says command not found
same thing on a mac
type gibberish we get command not found
same thing over here on my windows
machine although i'm running linux on
windows
and i get command not found okay
hopefully not that surprising
so what we want to do is type commands
that actually make sense that the
computer can figure out what we're
referring to and then run some
corresponding program for us and the
first really simple one i'm going to
show you is maybe not that useful but
it's just a good demonstration of a
simple command it is who am i all one
word no spaces
who am i all lowercase it's going to
print the username of the currently
logged in user so maybe not something
you need to do all the time
you probably know who you're logged in
as though there are uses for this
especially in scripting
if you write scripts later on but anyway
if i just run it here who am i
over here on my ubuntu installation i am
logged in as colt that is the username i
have
here's my mac here on who am i my
username is slightly different it's my
full name called steel
and i think on windows it's just
cult as well
all right so that's our first official
command really really simple hopefully
nice and straightforward right there's a
difference between just typing gibberish
and typing a command that is recognized
but it is important to note you know who
am i like this
is not the same thing at all
uh there's no
real auto complete or spell check or
anything like that uh the terminal is
just gonna take what you what you give
it and try and find that program so it
can't find this program
who am
it only knows who am i
okay so the next command we'll look at
is called man
the man command m-a-n is short for
manual
and that's exactly what it is it is a
command that doesn't do anything to our
system it's purely informative it tells
us information or manual pages for
commands
as well as some other things not just
commands but we're going to focus on the
command side of things so anytime we
have some new command like we just
learned who am i we can actually run
man
followed by that command name to get a
manual page entry for that command so if
we need to learn more about who am i or
any other command most likely you won't
need to learn more about who am i
because it's so simple
but we can do just that we can run man
followed by a command like who am i
hit enter
and our screen changes pretty
drastically that prompt goes away i
can't type commands anymore
what we see here is a man page it tells
us the name of the command prints the
effective user id
something called a synopsis will come
back to this when we learn some other
commands and then a description
print the username associated with the
current effective user id
pretty straightforward there's not a
whole lot here we can see who wrote the
command
and we can find a place to report bugs
this is a very simple man page some
commands have very long pages
dozens and dozens of pages you would
actually need to scroll through
now important to note first of all to
get out of here
we need to type the letter q if you
forget that you can find it down here
but remember i am not at my prompt right
now i can't type commands so i can't
type who am i if i type things i start
to see a whole bunch of other texts
appear i'm actually looking at some help
that tells me more about how this
program works so it tells me you know
you can exit by typing q or uppercase q
or
zz
you can type h to display the help page
that i'm looking at right now
so that's what happened i typed who am i
hit h but anyway i'm going to type q to
get out of there uh now i'm back to the
man page for who am i and i'll type q
again so just one more time if i type
man followed by some command
if i want to get out of here type q and
now i can type commands again
so if i try and run man on its own
it's going to tell me what manual page
do you want this is a manual command i
need to know what you want a manual for
so we can actually do man man
and that gives us the
man page for the man command it's an
interface to the system reference
manuals there's a bunch here
one thing i'll just point out quickly is
that we can scroll by using the mouse
that is one option but it's a lot easier
to scroll one page at a time by hitting
space
there's a lot of text here and i can
scroll down by hitting space
rather than having i can also use the
arrow keys by the way to go one line at
a time up and down which is what i'm
doing right now
space to go down a page at a time q to
get out of here all right so that's the
man command
nice and simple hopefully
very useful especially when we have more
complicated commands the next command is
also nice and straightforward it is
called clear
c-l-e-a-r
and this command will clear your
terminal screen
it is useful although i'll also show you
a shortcut that you can use in place
that's actually much shorter
so c-l-e-a-r will clear the mess on your
screen if you have a bunch of stuff here
like i do uh c-l-e-a-r enter and it's
gone
so i'll just show another example of
that over here
this is on my mac let's do some more
commands how about man clear let's just
take a look at that
here is the manual page for the clear
command it clears the terminal screen so
i'm going to hit q to get out of here so
i have a bunch more stuff
let's just pretend that's all valid
commands i want to get rid of it clear
all right nice and easy now let's take a
look again at the man page for clear
this is on ubuntu
and i want to talk about this right here
the synopsis
so we see the name it's clear here's a
little description it clears the
terminal screen nice and easy
now the synopsis is actually showing us
the syntax the accepted options and
values we can pass to the clear command
so clear is a command that accepts an
option we can see
if you see anything in square brackets
here it means it's optional
so you can pass this in you can pass
this
uppercase v lowercase x now what does
that mean
well commands accept options that alter
their behavior you can change how a
command functions so if we scroll
further down
we can see under options a description
of what these different options do
now the one i want to talk about is dash
x now i don't use this frequently but
it's just a good intro to options here
it says that it does not attempt to
clear the terminals terminal's
scrollback buffer
using the extended e3 capability i have
no idea what that part means but what
this means overall is that when we clear
with the dash x option
it is not going to clear our scroll
history so i'm going to get out of here
and demonstrate this so i'm going to hit
q
and let's make some history in here
hello there
i
love you okay none of those are valid
commands
i can scroll back and you know see those
commands and if i type regular clear
it's gone i can't scroll back that
history is gone now if i recreate some
of that hello there i
love you a lot if i use clear but this
time i provide dash x and that's our
first example of an option uh there will
be tons of commands we see that accept
options and they drastically they can
drastically change the behavior of a
command i'm going to hit enter
and it clears
but i can scroll
so i don't use that often honestly
i'm not showing it to you because it's
something you need to know i'm showing
it to you because it's an intro to
options
now one more thing i mentioned there's a
shortcut and i don't really type the
clear command anyway
the shortcut is ctrl l so if i have a
bunch of stuff again i want to get rid
of it
ctrl l and it's gone so that's
definitely easier than typing clear
it also works over here on my mac it
works on wsl just control l
okay so that's the clear command nice
and easy the next command is also nice
and easy it is pwd
it stands for print working directory
and this is a command that just tells us
our current location in a given terminal
window
so let's start with man pwd
and it tells us pwd prints the name of
your current slash working directory so
just like when we have i'll open up my
file explorer here with my graphical
user interface using my mouse
i have a current directory that i'm
inside of i'm viewing right now my
desktop as you can see it's selected
there
or i can view documents
or i can view my home folder
this would be my current working
directory home
in this window right here but in a
terminal it's a little bit different let
me get out of this man page here hit q
if i type pwd
it tells me in text where my location is
so in this window i am on the desktop
which is located in the cult folder
instead of slash home
over here this is a different terminal
window it has a different location just
like i can have multiple file picker
windows here's another one this one's in
my home directory and this one's in
desktop same idea so i can have in this
case pwd a terminal window that is in
slash home slash cold slash bin and
here's one more different window
a much longer path this is the full path
to get to my location
now i haven't shown you how to move so
you probably don't
have something like this set up with
these different windows
by default you can actually configure
the default location of a new terminal
window for me when i make a new terminal
window just click that button there you
can also use a shortcut it defaults to
the desktop at least on ubuntu over here
on my mac when i make a new window it
defaults to what is called my home
directory slash users slash my username
you can configure all of this but it
doesn't really matter where you are at
the moment all that matters that you can
find it by typing pwd
alright so the next command we're going
to cover is called ls the ls command is
short for list and we use it to do just
that it will list the contents of a
folder so we can see
what is inside of a directory
you know normally if you're using a
graphical user interface you don't need
a command you just can see the contents
of a folder but in a terminal window
that is not how things work at all we
have to ask for a list of the contents
so here i'm on my desktop
as we can see i ran pwd it says slash
desktop you can also see my prompt is
displaying desktop there as well
that is also something you can configure
by default though on ubuntu it does show
you your current location
anyway if i actually look at my desktop
i can see a bunch of stuff there
and i can list it out using the ls
command
so if i run ls with nothing else just ls
it's going to list the contents of
whatever current directory i'm inside of
in this window it's the desktop and here
we go we get a bunch of text so we see
things like you know my folders uh some
of them are quite odd here i've got
wildlife i've got uh i've got files like
greatgatsby.txt
so there's some different colors and
folders for me our bolded
files are not bolded and they're just
showing up white but that's all
configurable as well
but this is showing me all the contents
of my desktop if i try it somewhere else
here i'm in this slash bin directory
i'll type ls i see different contents
uh here that's my desktop desktop
all right well let's try it on my mac
here this is my home directory
um i see a bunch of other stuff right
this is different i see folders for my
courses i make my desktop my documents
labs some random things that you need to
get rid of like hello.js and
orange.python
those are my files and folders
now we also can provide a folder that we
want to look inside of we can provide a
path to ls so instead of just looking at
our current location i could peak
somewhere else
so for example
right here
let's see i'm on my desktop
and we saw that there is a wildlife
folder
on my desktop i could ask what is inside
of there by running ls
wildlife and i can tab complete so i
don't have to type the whole thing
and hit enter
and i have no idea why i have a wildlife
folder that contains three
text files called angela one and nico
survey it doesn't sound like wildlife to
me but okay i've got a meal diary folder
let's take a look in there
and it has nested folders inside
so now we can even burrow further in if
we wanted to from my current location on
the desktop i could look and set a meal
diary and look inside of friday
by doing this
ls meal diary slash
fry
and i'm using tab complete so i'm giving
it a path a path that is beyond it's not
just one folder name it's now two
that i want it to peak inside of so peek
inside of this
and we have breakfast dinner and lunch
so i can actually run this again and
let's see what's inside of breakfast i
don't know if there's anything in there
i'm gonna recall the previous line by
hitting the up arrow and then just add a
b and hit tab
yeah there's nothing in there no it's a
bit of a letdown
so that's one example of using ls where
we provide a file or rather a folder
path but we can provide a full what's
called an absolute path to any location
on our machine
so this file breakfast or this folder is
inside of friday is inside of meal diary
which is nested in the desktop which is
where i currently am
right pwd i'm on the desktop but maybe i
want to see what's inside of my
documents folder and documents is not on
my desktop
well one option is to do this ls
and then the full path to my documents
which is slash home slash colt slash
i think it's uppercase
documents so i'm using tab completion
again so i don't type that myself
i don't know if there's much in there
nope just a single file but we can see
kenneth.txt
now i could get there right by just
opening the file picker going to
documents yes i see it
but there are some special things that
we can do with the ls command in the
terminal as well but just to recap what
i showed there we can provide what's
called a relative path so relative to
our current location i could just say
show me list the contents of meal diary
but that only works if i'm on the
desktop
if i'm somewhere else i can't just
reference meal diary i need to reference
the full path
and that's exactly what i did down here
to get to documents the documents folder
is not in my desktop so i can't do ls
documents
it's going to tell me i don't know what
you're talking about that doesn't exist
here on the desktop
but if i provide the full path this is
the unique location the absolute
location of documents i can see it's not
exciting but i can see there's one file
all right so now let's talk about some
of the options ls accepts so let's use
that clear command or use ctrl l
and then let's run man ls
it tells us it does list directory
contents
and then it says that there's a bunch of
different options and i'm going to
scroll through them these are all the
options
a lot of them
most of them i don't use
doesn't mean they're not useful they're
just there's a lot
i want to highlight two that are very
useful the first one is dash l
so let's find it here
dash l come on h i j k l
doesn't tell us much but it says it will
use a long listing format so this means
i can take a look around with ls
and rather than just getting the file or
folder name i can instead add dash l
and get a whole bunch of other
information
so there's a lot we're not going to go
over here but there's file permissions
there's the owner of the file
there's the group owner there's file
size information
modification date the file name so a lot
of stuff here
for each individual file
so that is dash l
now another thing we'll take a look at
another option i'm going to go back to
man ls
is dash a
now dash a you can also do the longer
form dash dash all
all it says is that it does not ignore
entries starting with a dot when i just
type ls i don't see any files or folders
that start with a dot
ls dash a
i now see quite a few
dot bash a bunch of stuff
dot profile dot less something dot
pseudo something there's probably some
different ones on your machine i'll just
try another example here ls-a
on my mac lots and lots of files that
start with dot
they don't show up if i do a regular ls
which you can see right there
nothing starts with a dot
now we can combine options as well
so if i want to and clear this screen i
can do ls dash a
to see all files including ones that are
hidden dash l i want the long format
that is one way of doing it but the much
shorter and more common way is actually
just using a single dash and put your
options together so dash a l or dash l a
i see the long format
all the information for regular files
and files and folders that start with a
dot so we're getting both of those
options uh taking effect at the same
time
so that's an intro to the ls command so
we've seen how to find our current
working directory where we are and list
the contents of that directory now how
do we move around how do we do the
equivalent of what i'm doing right here
in the file explorer
double clicking on
you know desktop and then going into
this folder or going back how do i move
around like i am right here
well in the terminal the way that we do
that is by using the cd command cd is
short for change directory now the first
thing you'll notice if you try and read
the man page for cd
it does not exist
it just isn't there when i try it on my
mac
i see something but it is not a man page
4 cd if we look up here it's a man page
for
a bunch of commands tons and tons of
commands including cd well what's going
on here is that the cd command is
actually implemented by the shell we
don't need to dive into the specifics
really at all just i want you to know
that you're not going to find a super
helpful man page for cd it's one of the
few commands that we'll cover that does
not have a man page however you can run
help it's a different command
it's like the shell's version of man
help space cd
and it's kind of annoying it just prints
out text
you don't enter that program where you
can scroll nicely it just takes up a
whole bunch of text but it does tell us
it changes the shell working directory
change the current directory
there are some options we're not really
going to use those however
let's just see how it works so i'm going
to clear my screen first of all remind
you where i am in this window i am in my
home
cult folder
if i type ls
i see a bunch of other folders so let's
say i want to move into one of those
folders how about my desktop
well the way that i do that is by
writing cd
and then specifying that path
so i'm just going to do d e tab
hit enter
and you'll see my prompt changes
if i type pwd you can see my location
has changed to be home slash cult slash
desktop
before it was just home slash colt
so i just jumped i just double clicked
into that folder but i didn't click
anything it was all done via the
terminal
so i type ls i'm on the desktop now
let's go into the meal diary folder cd
into meal diary
all right and we're now in here
i can cd into how about friday
type ls or pwd you can see
i'm now at this pretty long path
if i type ls let's cd into
breakfast
so that's a really common thing ls and
then immediately after cd you you use ls
to look around and then cd
to change directories into something
that you just found
so now i'm in this folder breakfast and
i've hit a dead end there's no more
folders to cd into
uh how would i back out right normally
if i did the exact same thing so on my
desktop with the graphical user
interface it was
meal diary is that right
if i can find that
i double click friday breakfast
okay how do i go somewhere else well i
have a bunch of options i can hit the
back button i can use these buttons up
top to jump around
but here
how do i go back with the cd command
well the answer is to use cd followed by
dot dot
so two dots is a special path that
indicates or it refers to the parent
directory
so it's how i can back up one folder
right now i'm in breakfast
if i cd
dot dot
now i've gone back one level into friday
pwd you can see i'm in friday type ls
this is the contents of the friday
directory
so that's how i can go back one level i
can go back further
and repeat it
and now i'm back on my desktop
now i can also instead of just cding
into one folder at a time one level at a
time i can jump to any location on my
machine as long as i have the full
correct path
so if i wanted to go back to
where we just were which was this
location here right desktop meal diary
friday slash breakfast i could do that
in one step cd
and then meal diary slash friday i'm
using tab slash breakfast
so i don't have to do three separate cds
i can jump as many levels as i want and
the same actually goes for moving
backwards
i don't have to do cd dot dots enter cd
dot dot enter uh if i want to move back
multiple levels i can chain it together
i can do this this is one option
so it's a little clunky to do it this
way but it does work
so this is going to take me back one
parent folder and then its parent folder
and its parent folder
and now i type pwd i'm back on the
desktop
i can also pass in absolute path to cd
so everything we've done has been
relative to our current location but if
i want to go to my documents folder well
it's not here it's not in the desktop i
can't do cd documents if i try
it doesn't know what documents folder
i'm talking about it's only looking in
my current location and there's nothing
called documents on the desktop my
documents folder is located at this path
it is slash home slash cult slash
documents
and i can jump right there it doesn't
matter where i am i can run that command
anywhere
and i'll be able to get to documents i'm
now in documents
one other note around cd and path names
you'll see this tilde that refers it's a
shorthand
that is eventually expanded into your
home directory now it's kind of
confusing because this is called home
but the home directory for each user is
a directory with their username so for
me it's colt
so if i cd to tilde
and i do pwd it takes me to slash home
slash colt if you cd to tilde it will
take you to whatever your usernames
folder is and this folder is a very
important place it has the desktop it
has documents downloads a whole bunch of
stuff you can put your own things in
here too but even just if you do nothing
it contains a lot of important folders
and documents
uh so that's kind of the basics of cd
you can cd into a location that's
relative to where you are like
desktop
i can do multiple levels at once i can
back out with cd.dot
we combine it often with ls take a look
around where do i want to go let's go
into
wildlife cd wildlife
okay i got some stuff in here
and
i'm not gonna do anything with it let's
back out and i can also pass an absolute
path at any point uh which is again a
full path name not relative to our
current location
so that is the cd command so next up i
want to talk a little bit more about
folder structure
and how things are organized if you
noticed when i talked about absolute
paths all absolute paths started with a
forward slash and the reason for this is
that the very very highest level
directory on our machine is the slash
directory also known as the root
directory which is really confusing
people call this root but there's also a
directory called root r-o-o-t
definitely confusing uh in the same way
that people refer to uh you know my home
directory
colt if that's my username that would be
colt's home directory but there's also a
directory called home
it's uh yeah it's not the most
straightforward thing so the top level
directory is slash we can actually go
there if we wanted to
from anywhere on my machine i can do cd
slash
and if i take a look around
we've got a bunch of stuff that we
normally don't mess with at least not as
a typical day-to-day user
if you start writing scripts if you
start doing admin stuff absolutely there
are changes you can make here but we can
look around there's a bunch of different
files or folders and things called uh
sim links that we'll learn more about
later on in this video
um and that's kind of all i'm going to
show in this directory because there's
just so much here
uh but what i want to mention is that
your desktop your documents your music
your whatever files and folders you make
typically are going to live inside of
the home directory
inside of your particular username
so for me my username is colt we can
always find that out if i need to it's
also just right here in my prompt cult
so i can go into the home directory
i'll cd into that
if i take a look around every user on my
machine has their own unique home folder
so carrots cult elvis and kitty
let's take a look at kitty's directory
whoops not kits
kitty
and you can see we've got desktop
download documents pictures and all the
stuff that we would expect i'll back out
again
and then i'll go into
colt and this is where we've been
working
now
i just wanted to reiterate how this all
works slash is the root it's the top
level directory on our machine we cannot
go higher than that if i try and go to
slash and then
back out
i'm not going anywhere i'm just staying
right there at slash
now as i said every absolute path starts
with a slash because an absolute path is
the full location
the unique full location to reference a
particular file or folder so it always
starts with a slash
now another character that we've talked
about briefly is the tilde here which
refers to your individual home directory
so if i cd to tilde
i'm logged in as colt that will take me
to
slash home slash colt as you can see
right here
okay
and that's all i really wanted to
mention around folder structure of
course there's a lot more there's all
these folders there's dozens of folders
here that we're not going to discuss
everything we're doing lives inside of
our particular username home folder so
slash home slash lily slash home slash
colt
and then remember this difference
between relative and absolute paths if i
wanted to go
let's see where am i right now
i am in my home directory if i want to
go on to my desktop from here i can just
cd into desktop that is relative to my
current location but as we talked about
that only works if i am in a place where
i can view the desktop it's it is in my
current folder so basically the only
place this would work is from my home
directory right here
but if i go to slash i'm not going to be
able to just cd into desktop
i can't auto complete there is no
desktop right here
so i need to use an absolute path and i
could do the full long name cd slash
home slash cold
slash
desktop like that
or i can do the slightly shorter version
use that tilde character which refers to
my home directory slash desktop
okay
moving on the next command we'll cover
has to do with making directories or
making folders it is mkdir or make deer
mcdurr
however you want to pronounce it
it is short for make directory
and that's exactly what it does it's the
command we use to make folders
so the basic way we run it is make
directory or make deer space and then
some folder that we want it to create
for us and it will create that folder so
let's try it i'm going to cd just onto
my desktop
i'm going to clear control l
and i'm going to make a new folder here
i'm going to make a folder called
greenhouse i have a new greenhouse
actually and
i need to manage the crops that i'm
growing and starting seeds and bills and
maintenance and time sheets for
employees i don't know that's just
that's the story i'm going with
i'm going to make a folder called
greenhouse on my desktop so i'm on the
desktop right pwd there's no folder
called greenhouse you can see it's
alphabetical there's it goes from great
gatsby grep exercise keys
so if i run make directory
and then greenhouse
if that's the name of the folder i want
it to make me i'll hit enter
we don't see anything happen
but if i type ls again
we now have a folder called greenhouse
and if i just move this out of the way
you'll see on my desktop there's
greenhouse it's totally empty it's an
empty directory
so i can cd into that folder
and that's exactly what i'll do cd into
greenhouse oops i hit enter too early
green house there we go i use tab
complete again
and now i'm in here
so we can also make multiple folders at
once you just separate their names by
spaces
so i'm going to make
a winter and summer directory inside of
greenhouse make directory winter
and summer
so i can have you know different
schedules for what i'm growing in summer
and winter
i'll type ls and we see those two
folders were just created for me in my
current location right that's all i
specified was summer and winter i didn't
say any fancy path
but what i can do
is actually provide
if i wanted to make inside of summer i
wanted to make a folder called
how about you know seeds
i could do make directory
summer
slash
seeds
so i'm inside of greenhouse but i'm not
inside of summer
so in other words i'm right here in this
folder
i'm not going to go into summer and then
make a folder in two separate steps i'm
doing it in one step i just provide a
path
make the seeds directory instead of
summer i'll hit enter
okay
type ls i don't see it
but if i do ls summer
there we are i'm looking inside that
summer directory
there's my seeds folder
okay
now one last thing i'll show you there's
an option that's pretty common which is
dash p
which allows us to make nested folders
so why don't we just take a look at the
man page man for make directory
and we'll scroll down
here's p
or the long form dash dash parents
it says no error if existing make parent
directories as needed
so let me show you what it means when it
says no error
so inside of the winter folder which
i'll just point out here
graphically i want to make a seeds
folder and instead of seeds i want to
make a
lettuce folder
so if i try and do that all at once i'm
inside of greenhouse if i do make
directory winter slash seeds let me just
expand this window a bit here
winter seeds slash
did i say spinach no i said lettuce
if i hit enter here
i get an error it says can't create such
directory it runs into a problem because
it expects that winter slash seeds
already exists and it thinks it just
wants us or we just want it to make
lettuce that's not the case i want it to
make seeds and lettuce
but seeds doesn't exist it freaks out
but that's where the dash p option comes
in so make directory dash p
winter
seeds
slash lettuce we're now telling it make
any of the needed parent directories
along the way to make this lettuce
directory
we don't get an error and if i type ls
here we don't see anything but if i do a
lswinter
we see seeds if i do ls winter seeds we
see lettuce so it successfully made that
nested
directory and any necessary directories
along the way
so here's we go back winter
it made me seeds and inside of that it
made the lettuce so that's the dash p
option and that's really all there is to
make directory so mkdir followed by
whatever directory you want it to make
and some location for that directory
often it's just your current location
but you can provide a path a destination
as well so if i wanted to make something
all the way back in my home directory
which again i can use tilde as a
shortcut i could say make directory
tilde slash
blah blah i'm going to delete this once
i learn how to delete folders
i won't see anything here
but if i go all the way back to my home
directory
there it is
right there
so we can provide a relative path an
absolute path we just give it some
destination to make a folder and it
makes it for us that's make directory
the next command we'll cover is touch so
touch unlike most of the other commands
doesn't really tell you a lot about what
it does or its name doesn't indicate its
most common use make directory makes a
directory uh you know change directory
changes directory touch is used most of
the time at least to create files
so there's no create file or make file
it's just touch so uh we'll talk about
where that name comes from in a moment
but let's just try using it if we run
touch and we provide it with a file name
that doesn't yet exist it will make that
file for us so let me go to my desktop i
made a greenhouse folder
deny and then summer and winter let's cd
into summer
cd into seeds and let's make some files
here
so let me clear my screen i'm going to
make a file in here there's nothing at
the moment i'm going to make a file
called
how about squash
so squash i'm going to have a file full
of different types of squash seeds i
guess so if i just run squash as is
that's totally fine
squash if i type ls it made that file
for me i'll just show it to you also
visually if i go to my desktop
i'll go to greenhouse if i can find it
summer seeds here's my empty squash file
i can open it it's completely empty
okay so that's one option
i can also provide
an extension as i'm making a file so if
i want to make a txt file i can do dot
txt so let's make another one how about
berries how about just melon
another summer fruit
dot txt
and i now have a txt file called
melon.txt
now it's important to note that the
extension you provide it does depend on
the exact operating system you're
running but the extension does not
indicate
it doesn't it's not what's used to
determine the actual file type
of a brand new file so these are all
empty files i could make a pdf file if i
wanted to touch
apple.pdf
it's not really summer but
if i type ls we've got an apple.pdf
but they're all just completely empty at
this point if i look at any of these
files they are just plain old empty
files at the moment
of course i can put stuff in them i can
change that extension there's all sorts
of things we can do so let's try another
example i'm on my mac here
i'm going to touch multiple files so in
this directory it's called colors i have
a colors.txt file i'm going to make a
couple of new files let's go with red
dots pdf
and then a space orange dots
let's see how about png and then yellow
we'll do a different extension here how
about
an excel xls
i type ls
those files were created they're all
completely empty
now here is i'm on my mac this is finder
the graphical
user interface i've got red.pdf
orange.png
if i try and open one of these just with
my mouse
on a mac it does try and use preview it
does think that it's a pdf and it says
it's empty i don't know what to do with
that
if i try and do a pdf
it does use a pdf reader or pdf viewer
but again this is just on my mac if i go
back to ubuntu here and i open up a pdf
it just opens in a text editor if i open
up if i make a png file touch what's
another fruit how about barry.png
if i try and open that
oh it uses the text editor as well okay
so it does vary from one system to the
next
but the point is we just make empty
files with touch now let's talk about
when we provide a name of a file that
already exists
so if i run touch barry again i can do
that i can just hit the up arrow
it's
not going to seem like it does much it
doesn't make me a second file with the
same name that would be a problem what
it does instead is that it actually is
going to update the timestamp of the
file
so it touches it if we run man
touch
always a fun command to type out man
touch
uh it actually says its main purpose is
change file timestamps update the access
and modification time of each file that
we provide
so it says here secondarily a file
argument that does not exist is created
empty
so that's why it's called touch rather
than make full make file or create file
or something its main purpose at least
historically is to change the access and
modification times of a file
and then oh also if that file doesn't
exist it will make it as an empty file
so how do we know or how can we view the
access and modification times if we
remember ls-l that flag if we take a
look at
barry.png here
right there
october 15 1348 is the modification time
that's ls dash l is the long listing
format so 1348 let's see it's now 13.50
so if i try and touch barry.png again
and i do ls-l
we now see it's showing october 15th
1350.
so it does in fact update that
modification time
but most of the time 99 of the time that
i use touch it's to make files uh and i
can make a bunch of them at once as we
saw just provide a bunch of file names
separated by spaces and it will make
them for you
okay so we saw how to make files and
make folders let's talk about destroying
things so to delete a folder we can use
the rmdir remove directory command rmdir
followed by the name of a folder or a
path to a folder that we want to delete
or multiple separated by spaces however
this will only work if the folder is
empty
so over here
uh i've got
i don't have any folders let's make a
folder make directory uh delete me in
all caps
there it is to delete it one option is
rmdir
delete me i type ls and it's gone
but if i back out
and i try and delete
the seeds folder which is not empty
rmdir seeds
we get an error failed to remove seeds
directory is not empty
and that's really all there is to rm
deer it removes empty directories only
empty directories we'll see another
command we can use to remove directories
that have stuff inside of them so next
up we're going to talk about the rm
command rm for remove let's take a look
at the man page it says we can use it to
remove files or directories
so we saw how to use rm deer it only
works to remove an empty directory i've
got this seeds directory rmd or seeds
no luck it's not empty alright
so this is where the rm command comes in
i'm going to show you how to use it to
delete directories in just a moment but
we're going to start by deleting files
so i'm just going to make a couple files
with touch
uh how about cat dog carrot
um blue
all right so i have these four files now
i can delete them using rm followed by
let's do blue to start uh the name of a
file
and that's it it is gone now it's very
important to note uh there is no
intermediate recycling can or trash can
or something some sort of bin we can go
find all these files we've deleted they
are just completely gone they're just
vanished from our entire uh system
so that can be uh a bit of a scary thing
if you're not careful with what you're
deleting so you definitely want to make
sure you're only ramming things that you
mean to rm but the flip side of that is
that it's very
fast powerful quick and easy to delete
things uh just as long as it's not too
easy and you slip up
so we can delete multiple things
multiple files if we just separate them
with spaces of course like that carrot
cat and dog are all gone
so that's the basic use of rm
i'll show you one more there's a couple
of flags i want to talk about the first
flag is dash v
this is actually a trend there are many
commands that support a dash
v for verbose that option in the case of
ram will give us some verbose output
that that basically explains what it did
if you notice here we run it we deleted
three things but there's no feedback
it's just silently deleting them
we had to look to see are they gone well
if we use dash v i'm just gonna remake
my uh
four files again
if i use dash v so rm carrot cat dog
dash v for verbose
now it just tells me what it does each
step of the way removed carrot removed
cat removed dog
pretty straightforward hopefully
but the end result is exactly the same
you do not need to have that of course
it's just something you may want to use
some people like to use it
and like i said there are other commands
like when we see copy cp and move mv
we can use dash v for verbose output and
it will tell us just copied this file i
you know moved this file renamed this
file removed okay
so
that's one flag dash v the next thing i
want to talk about is using rm to delete
a directory
so we talked about rmd or does not work
on seeds or any folder that is not empty
so that must mean rm will work right
let's rm seeds
oh no cannot remove seeds is a directory
but i thought the whole point was you
know rm could delete a folder that has
stuff in it
yes that is the point uh but we have to
use a flag
and the flag we need to use is the r
flag for recursive so if i do man rm
again
i'll scroll down
a little bit further
r so we can do lowercase r uppercase r
or dash dash recursive if you really
have a lot of time to spend
and what this will do is it tells the rm
command to remove directories and their
contents so that could be other
directories and further nested
directories there could be hundreds of
levels of directories nested down
remove them all
so here's how we would use it if i want
to remove the seeds directory this is
what it has inside remember
it has four files
and i want to remove that entire
directory it's just
rm-r seeds
and once again there's no feedback i
could have added dash v and it would
tell us more but now it is completely
gone
that's it
so i'm going to make a directory again
we'll call this
zoo
let's cd into zoo i'm just going to
touch some random let's see animals cat
dog
snake
i don't know jaguar
okay
so uh i have that zoo directory now i'm
going to back out again
this time i'm going to delete it with
rm-r
but i'm also going to show you a new
flag dash i
for interactive and interactive
is going to prompt us and ask us if we
want to delete each file or not so if we
do dash i here
and then the folder which in this case
is zoo
now it's asking me do you want to
descend into this directory zoo so do we
want to go inside and see what's there
i'm going to say y for yes or if i said
no then we kind of end it all but i'll
do y
do i want to remove regular empty file
snake
yes
cat y for yes
let's keep jaguars i'm going to say no
dog
yes
and now it's asking me do you want to
remove the directory zoo uh i'm going to
keep it
so that interactive mode allows me to
make decisions uh if you're deleting you
know 10 000 files maybe not the best
option but
that is a flag we can use dash i to
interactively decide what to delete and
what to keep
so now if i look at zoo
it only has the jaguar file inside
one more quick demo i want to show you
i have a
let's see where did i put that my
desktop a directory called meals
and inside of meals i made 52 folders
one for each week of the year and inside
of each week if i just pick one like
week 35
there is a folder for each day of the
week and for each one of those days
there are three files breakfast lunch
and dinner dot txt so we've got three
files for each day of the week for 52
weeks of the year it's a lot of
files and folders nested i'll show it to
you here so this is the meals
directory
all these different weeks
pick one
pick another day all those files so
there's a lot of stuff going on here and
i just wanted to show you that i can
delete the entire thing very easily and
very quickly all those nested folders
and files using rm so i'm going to cd
back a couple levels
one more and one more
just to reiterate you know i don't need
to do cd dot dot cd dot cd dot dot to go
back three levels i could have done
that right there
or i could have just said take me to the
desktop specifically
so this would work from anywhere
this cd dot dot cd dot dot cd dot dot
only works if i'm three levels away you
know three levels burrowed down from the
desktop if that makes sense this will
work from anywhere
anyway
i have this meals directory i'm going to
remove it i need to do a dash r
and i'm going to make it verbose so you
can see exactly how many things it
removes in a single go so this is just
one command remember no recycling bin no
trash can these files are gone so you
obviously want to be careful but here we
go rm dash r for recursive so we can
delete a directory that has stuff in it
and dash v for verbose
and
if i scroll up i'm going to be scrolling
for a long time
lots and lots of files and folders
deleted in a split second so that's the
rm command it also does work to remove
empty directories
so um in that sense you kind of never
have to use rm deer i just show it as a
quick you know command that you may
encounter some people like it
because
you know that you're not going to be
accidentally deleting stuff that has a
bunch of contents inside of it but you
could just use the rm command in general
to delete files delete empty folders or
delete folders full of a bunch of stuff
as long as you use the dash r option all
right so that is rm the next command
i'll show you is one i use all the time
on my mac it's called open
and it will open a folder open a file
outside of the terminal in the the sort
of graphical world of our machine so if
i make a bunch of files
like uh
i don't know how about purple i'll just
make one dot txt if i now want to
do something with that file i don't know
i want to view it in finder well i could
navigate to it and figure out where this
is or i can do open
i could do open dots that will open the
current directory and here we go a
finder window with that directory but i
could also say open that particular file
and it opens it up in the default
application which is just a text editor
on my mac
but if i had some other file you know i
can find an example here
if i go to my desktop which i edited out
i've navigated here i've got a file uh
let's see
i've got a pdf file if i open that
it opens it up in my case using a pdf
editor the
default you know what it would open with
if i double clicked anyway so that's the
open
command but it is mac specific so again
i can do things like open dot to open
the current directory i can see all my
files and you know work with them here
if i need to
i can open a particular file and it's
pretty smart
but if i try this on ubuntu here
i've got two directories here if i try
and open that it's going to complain to
me it can't do it it doesn't know that
command
now there is an alternative which is x d
g dash open
and uh there we go it opens up you know
in this case this folder for me
if i have a file just call it touch
tomato.js
if i do xdg dash it's a bit of a
annoying one to type but
open tomato
it opens up the text editor and i can
start working on this file
now you may need to install it just to
be clear i think if on wsl here if i try
xdg open dot
well i need a dash there
it complains and it tells me i need to
install it using this command so you can
install that if you want
but this is one of the main differences
here open is a mac only command it might
be one of the i think it's the only one
we cover in this video that is different
between mac and ubuntu or linux the next
command we'll look at is mv for move
this is how we can move files around
it's also how we can rename files and
that's going to be the first use case
i'll show you if we run mv
followed by an existing file and then a
space and then a new file name
what this will do is
move pair
turn it into new pair it will rename it
so let's try an example here
uh oh got a lot going on here why don't
i make a new directory in here i'll just
call this um commands
i'll cd into there okay
i'm gonna make a file in here and i'm
gonna call this my journal
but i spell it wrong like that
and i wanna rename it i can use move let
me just show you there it is i can use
move and then the incorrect name
journal.txt
and then the new one
just like that
and again you may not get this verbose
output that's just a setting i have but
if we type ls we see journal.txt
now if you do want that verbose output
just for any of these commands
like
rm if i do m
v i get the man page for mv
there's an option in here
further down
dash v which explains what is being done
so if you want to know exactly what's
going on let's say i want to rename
journal
the correct version i want it to now be
an uppercase j i don't know why
if you add dash v
which mine have by default you'll get
that verbose output honestly i only put
that in there when i'm teaching so
people can see what's going on i don't
really care to get that confirmation it
yeah it's gonna work either way and we
can see it's been renamed
now we can also use move to change the
location uh not just rename you know in
the same directory but to move a file
back a directory or into a completely
different directory
so let's find an example of that let's
just make a directory here i'll call
this one
i don't know
stuff and i realized shoot i really
should have made that journal file
inside of stuff
well i can move it in there it's pretty
easy i can just do move
the thing i want to move and then
the move command is smart enough to know
that if the last parameter the last
argument is a folder
it will be the destination folder so i
can move
journal into stuff
and if i type ls i don't see journal
anymore if i look inside of stuff
it's inside our journal is inside of
stuff
i can also do that to multiple files at
once
so if i touch
i don't know about pi and
cake and cookie
sure i have these three files if i want
to move them into stuff i can do mv cake
cookie pie and then as long as stuff
comes last it will be the destination
folder
and there we go they are moved into
stuff
now there's more you can do with move
you can move folders around you can
rename folders so if i want to rename
stuff instead to be stuff in all caps
move stuff to be stuff
there we go i just renamed it
um so yeah that's probably all i'll show
you for move it's pretty powerful i use
it all the time to move things around
you know i could move this entire stuff
directory onto the desktop if i wanted
to
i could do
move
stuff
and then just have it go back
one directory right now i'm on this
commands folder i want it to go onto
desktop
it's not here anymore i'll cd back
and here it is on my desktop somewhere
there it is this is the one the
uppercase stuff all right so let's move
the next command i'll cover is cp which
is for copy we can use this to copy a
file or even copy folders
so if i make some file
i'm on my desktop here there's just too
much stuff going on
let's go back to my stuff directory
okay so i've got this journal file
if i want to make a new copy of it let's
say for today's journal sure i'm going
to copy it i can do cp
the thing i'm copying which is journal
and then the destination for the copy so
if i wanted to be in the same folder
then i don't need to do anything just
provide a name so how about
today's
today journal or something like that
and that makes me a copy
so i have journal and i have
todayjournal.txt
now these are all empty
so it's not that useful to show but
if they had content inside of them
like i'm on my mac here i have this
linuxcommandhandbook.pdf
if i want to make a copy of that cp
linuxcommandshanbook.pdf
and just give it a new name how about
handbook
dot pdf
just like that
if i type ls well there's gonna be a lot
of stuff on here but there is a
handbook.pdf file
and if i open it up
or just yeah i'll open it sure
you'll see that it is a full copy so
it's the entire linux handbook here all
these commands we've been covering so it
doesn't just copy empty files that's
very important we can also copy entire
directories so let's go back to ubuntu
where are you here we are
i've got this stuff directory why don't
we copy the entire stuff directory
so uh cp
stuff
and then i want to make a directory
called stuff
copy
well if i try that
we have a problem it says dash r not
specified omitting directory stuff it's
not going to copy this
well if we take a look at the man page
for cp
it tells us if i scroll down there is a
dash r option
which just like with remove rm stands
for recursive so if we want to copy the
contents of a directory and any nested
directories and their contents and so on
we need dash r
so let's replace this let's rerun it one
more time cp dash r
stuff
stuff copy i have that dash v verbose on
by default again you can turn that on if
you want or you can just run it with
dash v if you really want this output
but here we can see it made a copy of
the stuff folder
and all of its contents so if we take a
look here's my stuff copy
and inside of it
we have all of these files that have
been copied as well
so we can make copies like that i can
also move as i'm creating a copy so if i
want a copy of i don't know song of
myself
and i want it to go inside of
stuff copy
or instead of stop whatever let's go to
my desktop
i could do copy song is it capitalized
yes it is song of myself long poem and
uh let's actually put it
uh sure let's put it inside of stuff so
stuff slash and then i'm gonna call it s
o song of my self sure psalms dot dxd
all right so i'm gonna copy it but i'm
also moving it at the same time because
where i'm copying it to is a different
destination
i won't see psalms in here if i look in
stuff
cd into stuff
nope where did i put it
well wow i'm an idiot i put it inside of
stuff with lowercase how confusing it's
not in here it's going to be in this one
so if i cd into lowercase stuff
there it is
soms.txt all right so it is there
and that is a copy of that file so that
is the cp command the next command we'll
take a look at is called head so let's
look at the man page for head it says
that it outputs the first part of files
head and tail
are often used to refer in programming
to
two different ends of a structure in
this case a file the head of a file is
the beginning the tail would be the end
so it's a really simple command it just
prints out
by default i think it is the first the
first 10 lines of a file
but we can actually specify an exact
number using the dash n option but let
me just show you uh so i've got this
very long file
in here which is song of myself.txt it's
like hundreds of lines of long poem uh
if i run head
song of myself.txt
it just outputs the first 10 lines
now as we saw i can provide the dash n
option followed by a number like 100
and it prints the first 100 lines
from the beginning of the file
so there we go 100 lines and that's kind
of all that there is to head
now there's also a command called tail
let's look at man tail
and it unsurprisingly probably outputs
the end of a file so by default it's the
last 10 lines
but we can also provide an exact number
using dash n
uh and there are some other options here
as well but let's just start with that
so i'm going to do
tail
song of myself.txt here are the last 10
lines of song of myself
but i can also say i want the last 20
lines
and there we are i get the last 20. now
with tail i'm on my mac now
there's one option that we don't have
with head which is dash f where are you
here we are
dash f it says it causes tail to not
stop when the end of file is reached but
rather to wait for additional data to be
appended to the input
basically it's going to read the end of
a file and print it out but then also
keep printing out any new additions to
the end of that file this can be useful
for log files output files error logs
things that are changing and you want to
monitor them if i just do tail
this is a on a mac at least this
system.log file it doesn't matter
really but it's a file that contains a
bunch of stuff i honestly don't know
what half of it is
and if i don't have that dash f option
it just stops this is the last thing
printed out but if i add that dash f in
there
whoops i need to make sure i put dash f
in there first
now
my prompt does not come back
this file is being printed out the end
of it is being printed out and if i do
something that would add to that log
file if i i may i make a new window like
i just did i'll do it again
you can see that that log file is
changing content is being appended to it
so i'm getting a live and as i close as
well you can see things are changing i'm
getting a live update as i make a new
process or i kill a process
from this system.log file
whereas if i had just i can get out of
here by the way ctrl c
but if i had just done tail without dash
f
it's not live it just stops it shows me
exactly what's at the end of that file
right now but with dash f it keeps
listening and keeps updating the output
so that's tail so the next command i'm
going to show you is one that i don't
really use very much
i'm showing it to you actually because
it helps illustrate some other concept
so the command i'm going to show you is
called date it's really straightforward
d-a-t-e
and it just prints out the current date
and time
let's see i'm sure there's some other
options and different things we can do
we can specify how it should
display the dates
honestly we're not going to go into it
because as i mentioned i don't use very
much it can be useful though if you're
writing a script
and you need to get access to the
current time or the current date day of
the week that sort of thing
anyway the reason i'm showing it to you
is because i'm using it to illustrate
something that is not a standalone
command we're going to talk about
something called redirection
so this greater than sign right here
we can use to perform something called
redirecting standard output
so the date command or really any of the
commands we've seen if i do ls
not la
ls
or i do date or pwd
all of these
generate output and that output by
default shows up in our terminal right
it's printed out as text here
but we can actually redirect where that
information goes uh by sending it to a
file if we wanted to
so i can take the current date
and store the result instead of printing
it out store it in a file and to do that
i use the greater than sign again what
we're doing here is redirecting standard
output
okay
so let's make a file i'll show you we
don't actually have to make a file first
but i'm going to make an empty file i'll
call it
today.txt
uh there it is today.txt all right so
what i'm going to do next is redirect
date
so again the date command
greater than sign
today.txt and this tells the terminal
run this command first but whatever
output we get don't just print it out
instead we're redirecting the output
to this file
okay
and we don't see any output nothing is
printed out
if i type ls there we are we see today
is still there
now in a moment i'm going to show you a
command we could use to read this file
very easily but we do know head we've
already seen that so i could do head
today.txt
and take a look we see that it contains
that text
so what do you think will happen if i
recall this line
and i run it again
so take the current date whatever that
is that output and send it over to this
file
the file looks like this right now
right
if i run it again we'll get a different
time it's still friday the 15th of
october
but it's now for what 27. so this should
change
um but what you'll notice is that it
actually ends up replacing the contents
of that file so it's not added as a
separate line right we don't have two
dates in there now
it ended up replacing the entire
contents of the file so this is very
important if i had a lot of stuff in
there
for example
if i navigate back
i have this uh let's see
stuff directory lowercase stuff
i have this song of myself.txt
you do not need to follow along with
this but this file contains a lot of
text if i just look at the
first 10 lines it's the entire text of
that poem song of myself
now if i try and redirect something in
there i can take the output of pwd for
example
and redirect that
into song of myself.txt
now that is the only thing in that file
the output of pwd
so we have another option
which is to use a different operation
very similar we use two greater than
signs and this allows us to redirect
standard output while also appending to
a file instead of overwriting the file
entirely
so if i just ran you know pwd
and then two greater than signs
into this file this is let's do it a
couple times this is silly to do but if
i take a look at that file
it now contains what five different
lines let's take the date and redirect
it into there
let's take uh who am i
and redirect it into there
okay now let's take a look at that file
again
and you'll see it contains the output of
pwd five times the date and then who am
i which in this case is colt let's do
date one more time or a couple more
times let's run head
and you can see
it did not overwrite the entire file it
just appends onto the end
so
you know date i don't use very much at
all redirection though both with a
single greater than sign which
overwrites a file and two greater than
signs is really really common uh the
last thing i'll mention is that you can
do something like this date redirect
into today.txt that file does not exist
in this folder if i take a look there is
no today
but if i do
date
redirect into today.txt
we now have a today file it made it for
us so the file does not have to exist in
order to uh you know redirect output to
it uh it will make that file for us if
it needs to
all right so we can do it with the date
command we can do it with really any
command that generates output as we saw
i mean i could do if i wanted to
ls
or ls-l that gives me a lot of text
i could take that and then redirect that
to a new file called you know
contents how about that
and
if we take a look at contents we'll just
use head for now this is what the first
10 lines are now there may be yeah i
think there's some more that's missing
but we're just doing the first 10
and we can see what is inside that file
so that's the basic concept of
redirecting and then of course if we use
2
greater than signs we are redirecting
by appending to a file the output is
appended to contents and now
if we do head we'll probably need to
specify you know i want
how about just 40 lines of that file
we can see all of this is in there
all right so next up we have another
command called cat c-a-t
and let's start by just taking a look at
the man page for cat
the name cats comes from the fact that
it concatenates files
cat
but the first use i'm going to show you
is something slightly different on its
own if we just run cat i'm just going to
clear here
cat and then a file name like i have
this uh
song of myself i actually don't think
there's we we overwrote that didn't we
but if i do cat and then a file name it
just prints the contents of that file
in this case to my standard output to
the terminal
if i have and we had that contents file
that we just made cat
contents
it gives me the entire file so it
doesn't like head gives us the first 10
by default we can specify the first 20
lines the first 30 lines tail gives us
the last 10 the last 20. cat gives us
the entire file
so i've got this song of myself file
very long if i cat
song of myself it prints out the entire
thing
there's a lot here you know i'm
scrolling for a very very long time
all right so that is something we can do
but that's yeah sometimes i'll use that
if i want to just check on you know
what's in that file i don't remember
what's it look like we can do that
but there's a lot more we can do with
cat as well remember the name cat comes
from concatenate
so we can actually provide more than one
file name and it will print the contents
of both of those or three or four
however many files it will print all
their contents together so on my desktop
i have
quite a few messy files here i've got
one called letters so i'm just going to
cat letters
all right it just contains letters and
then i have this one called words i'm
going to cat words
and there we are okay so i can cut them
individually or i can cut them together
just by separating them with a space and
now we end up with one output again not
very exciting
but two different files for red and then
concatenated together in this output
smushed together
so that doesn't seem that useful but
where it gets more exciting if
exciting to stretch but where it gets
more sometimes useful is that we can
then redirect that output to another
file so i could make one file that is a
combination of two or three or four
other files or it doesn't have to stop
at four i just don't want to keep saying
numbers
but we can take multiple files
concatenate them together and take that
output and save it into another file so
here's an example of that i have three
different shopping lists one for the
butcher we can just take a look at that
i need ground pork ground beef sausage
skirt steak i've got one for the feed
store for my animals i need to get
chicken scratch chicken feed oyster
shells i've got one for groceries milk
eggs butter onions tomatoes
all right so i want a master list
still contrived but you know i want one
list that i can take with me so i can
concatenate all of them butcher
feed store groceries
and then i will take that first we can
just see what it looks like here's the
concatenated output but instead of
printing it let's redirect it into a
file we'll call it
everything if i can spell everything
okay and now we have a new file called
everything let's take a look at it
it contains the results of those three
other files being concatenated so that
can be useful right we can take multiple
things stuff them together and put it in
another file but as we'll see later we
can also actually take multiple things
concatenate them and send them to other
commands not just send them to a file so
we'll cover that later on when we talk
about piping one last thing with cat
that i'll mention is that we can use the
dash n option to get line numbers
so maybe not that useful here but if i
go back with that super long song of
myself poem
if i do cat dash n song of myself
pretend this is a file with you know
some code and there's a problem in here
i can find
that line number and then tell my
co-worker hey it's on 1741.
you would probably be in an editor but
we'll also learn about some other
commands like find and grep which allow
us to search for things so we'll get
there
there are valid use cases for for
wanting those line numbers to be
available
all right
the next command we'll look at is called
less
l-e-s-s less
is used to
read the contents of files it gives us a
nice interactive ui where we can scroll
and it's just a lot easier to work with
a file compared to looking at the
contents that is printed out from cat so
just as a reminder here i've got this
super long file song of myself if i use
cat
it prints out the entire thing and i
guess that's sometimes useful but in a
super long file i've got a scroll
forever yes i could use head or tail
just to get you know the the very top or
the very bottom of the file but this is
a lot of scrolling
so if i wanted to actually go through
this and i wanted to read the entire
poem or look at a massive log file from
scratch all the way at the beginning i
could use cat scroll to the beginning
and now just use a terminal and scroll
down but it's not that easy it's not a
great interface but if i use less
followed by the file name so any file
name but a long one is ideal because
you'll be able to see how useful it is
less song of myself.txt
now my screen changes it didn't just
print out the entire text to my terminal
window instead
it opens up the less program where i see
a page and then i can scroll down with
arrow keys
just like the man pages so if you
remember with the man pages if we open
up man some command
our prompts goes away we're transported
to a new world of man pages and we can
scroll i can hit space to go one page at
a time
and there's quite a bit more we can do
in less but first most importantly to
get out of here
cue just like the man pages so my my
history my terminal is not cluttered
with thousands of lines of text
so that's one benefit but also of course
i can read things and scroll up my own
pace
i can also do things like search so if i
want to search in here my cursor is
right here
it's a little hard to see
if i type a forward slash and then i
type some phrase or something i'm
looking for
i don't know let's look for
green i don't know if green is in here
somewhere but let's see i'm going to
type green and hit enter and there we go
this is the first match the sniff of
green leaves and dry leaves
so that's one thing we can do by the way
i mentioned you can scroll one page at a
time down by hitting the space bar
we can scroll up one page at a time by
hitting b so b in space
we can also use arrow keys up and down
we can jump to the end of the file i
believe by hitting g
capital g yeah we need shift g it takes
me to the very end of the file and then
lowercase g takes me to the start so
here's the very beginning
uppercase g takes me to the end and as
always q is how i can quit so this is
great to work with long files
it's just easier to navigate you can
search for things
unlike if you're just looking at an
entire file using cats it's just all
vomited on your screen all at once so
that's less the next command we'll learn
is called echo echo uh it's very simple
it does one thing it takes whatever
value whatever argument we pass it and
it echoes it back it just prints it back
it outputs it so that might not seem
useful let's get out of here let's clear
if i just echo hi
well it just echoes high back to me it
prints it out
so yeah it is not that useful when you
just run it like that
but one really useful trick is to use
echo with a piece of text and then
redirect the output to a file
so this is a great really fast way of
making a new file that contains some
little bit of text
without even having to open up the file
so if i needed to make some config file
and it needs to contain
i'm just making this up but it needs to
contain something like
you know username equals cult something
like that it needs to have one line in
that file
well i could make an empty file i could
open it up and then i could put this in
there save it close the file or
i can echo it and then redirect to a
file that doesn't even exist yet
so that file let's just call it config
dots we'll just do txt
so it's going to take this argument it's
going to echo it back but instead of
printing it to the terminal i'm
redirecting it to a file that doesn't
even exist it will make that file and
put this piece of text in it so now
we have a config file and if we use cat
to look at it
there we are it contains that line
and i can also you know if i needed to
add something to it
i can do the same thing where i can
append with two greater than signs so if
i needed some other config in there i
don't know how about
key equals
that
that is now appended into our config
file if we take a look
there we are it has two lines of text in
it so this is not how i would recommend
editing files but if you need to make
something quickly or just add a small
thing to a file quickly this is a really
great way of doing it echo some piece of
text redirect it into a file so to
summarize echo on its own some piece of
text
it echoes it back to you on the terminal
it just prints it out
but we can also redirect that and it's a
great way to add some text to a file in
like two seconds so the next command
we'll cover is called wc it's short for
word count and it does just that it
counts the words in some input
for now it's going to be a file but we
can actually provide other inputs and it
does more than just word count it
actually will count the bytes and the
lines so if you remember i have this
very long song of myself file here
i want to know how many lines are in it
well if i run wc
and then song of myself
it tells me well there's three different
values here the first one is a number of
lines
1757 lines the next one is the number of
words
and then third this little chunk here uh
that is the number of bytes and then the
name of the file
so if we look at the man page for wc
you'll see that it tells us the order
again how many lines how many words and
how many bytes
we can also say actually i just want the
lines so we can use dash l or i just
want the number of characters dash m
or the number of words dash w
so let's see how many
uh let's see how many lines i don't want
all that other stuff and we're gonna do
wc-l
song of myself.txt
there we are i want to know how many uh
how many words dash w
song of myself we get fifteen thousand
seven six seven
okay
so that's one way of using word count
but i'm also introducing a new concept
right now something called piping
so we're directly passing right now a
file to word count but with piping we
can do something very different we can
actually take the output of one command
and pass it as the input to a second
command
so we saw how to take the output of some
command like ls and redirect it to some
file this is taking output
and then putting it in a file
but what i'm talking about is taking
output of a command and passing it to a
second command
so what if i wanted to know how many
files are in here so if i do ls-l
this is a massive chunk of text right
i can take this
and i could i guess take it redirect it
to a file and count the lines in that
file
or
i can use piping so it's called piping
because we use the pipe character
located above the return key on the
right side of my keyboard
i take the first command ls-l
and then instead of just printing out
the output i want to pipe it to the word
count command wc
and take a look at that we see the
number of lines new line characters
number of uh
geez words and the number of bytes
uh so what we just did was take ls-l i
could even do let's do al that will
include hidden files if i have any here
there's just two of them but we have 64
lines now
so that's just one quick example but we
can also do things like combine two
different files using cat and then pipe
that to word count and word count is not
the only command we can pipe to i'm just
introducing that one first uh i could
even do date
pipe that to word count if i wanted to
know how many bytes are in there or how
many uh words it's one line
i don't know if i'd really want to do
that but we definitely can
but i have a couple of let's go actually
to
my shopping once again
and i have if you remember this butcher
file
and feed store well actually let's do
groceries so i have butcher and
groceries i want to know how many things
i have to buy
so i'm going to combine those two
groceries and butcher with cat so cat
groceries and butcher and remember on
its own it just smushes them together
and prints it out
but i'm not going to redirect it to a
file i'm going to pipe it to word count
and there we go if i just want the lines
that will tell me tell me how many items
right one item per line and it says nine
and that seems correct right one two
three four five six seven eight nine
different things that i have to buy
all right so that's an intro to piping
it will pop up again and again as i
introduce some other commands that are
really more useful when you pipe things
to them
one more thing i just i'll show quickly
i can combine piping and redirection if
for some reason i wanted to take this
output
and then redirect it to a file called
number.txt i can do that so this will
run first
concatenate those two files
and then we're taking that information
and piping it to the word count command
which is just going to give us a number
of lines in this case nine and then
instead of printing that out like we did
here
redirect it to a file called number.txt
there it is number.txt and if we look
inside
well it just has the number nine so
that's a quick intro to piping
next up we'll see some other commands we
can pipe to the next command we'll talk
about is sort
so sort does what it sounds like it
sorts information we'll start by just
sorting a text file
so i have this
why don't we start with our everything
file so let's take a look at that
okay so it has a bunch of different
items
and i'm going to sort them
with sort everything.txt
now this is not going to change the file
itself this is simply sorting the output
it's going to sort what it gets from
this file it will read it in sort it and
print out the sorted information but it
does not store it in that file
and you'll see we end up with an
alphabetical sort by default so butter
chicken feed chicken scratch eggs ground
beef ground pork
it is case sensitive so an uppercase s
comes before a lowercase s
and you can actually tell it to not be
case sensitive i believe if we look at
man sort
there is an option in here for
where is that ignore case dash f
um but this is great this is you know
sorting a file alphabetically but just
to reiterate it is not changing that
everything file
it is unsorted
now i could redirect of course so i can
do this sort everything and then put it
into a file called sorted everything
and now if we look at that sorted
everything file it is indeed sorted
we also can tell it to sort numerically
so if i had a file that had numbers in
it okay i have a file called nums i've
just created oop
nums
it just contains five numbers here if i
try and just sort nums as is
it doesn't do a numeric sort it does
well it sort of does it compares you
know the first digit of each and a two
so these both have a two that means i
guess they come before 54 because that
starts with a five but it's not an
actual numeric sort
but we have the dash n option
that will now sort things numerically
and there are other sorts that we have
at our disposal we can reverse things
with the dash r option so let's do that
dash n r you can see we now have 999
first all the way down to the number two
another option that can be useful has to
do with duplicate values so why don't i
echo
999
and i'll append that into my nums file
i'll do that a couple of times all right
so now when i recall my sorts for nums
there's a bunch of those 999s in there
if i want to only get the unique values
i can use the dash u option for unique
so let's do dash n u
and now i only get the unique numbers
sorted
alright so that sorts we can concatenate
and pipe information to sort
we can do all sorts of things right it
doesn't have to be from a file so i'll
just show one more example of that let's
take the butcher file and the
what's another file i have groceries
okay and if i want to sort those two i
can pipe that oops
i don't know if you can hear my cat
there
i can pipe it to sort and there we are
it sorts what it received as its input
so it wasn't just one file we took one
command cat that gets an output we pipe
it over to sort
so there we go
i could also do things like if i wanted
to know how many unique numbers
are in this numbers file right nums
i could sort nums
but i only want the unique so dash u n
sort whoops not sort
nums
and then let's imagine there was like
hundreds of them instead of what five i
could pipe that over to good old word
count and ask for how many lines
so take this nums file
only sort the unique value sort them
numerically but instead of printing the
value or the output to the terminal pipe
it over to word count where we count the
number of lines and the grand total is
5. so this just is to show you that you
know we can take sorts
and pipe its output to something we can
redirect its output to a file or we can
take some other command like cats
and concatenate two files and then pipe
the output to sort
so that's sort next up we'll talk about
the unique un iq command now the unique
command
is generally at least when i use it used
in conjunction with the sort command
so unique
is going to let's just take a look at
the man page first
it reports or omits repeated lines
so anytime you have a data set or a file
that contains repeated information on
different lines and you're trying to
either consolidate it or ignore repeated
lines we can use the unique command
so just show an example
i have a
file here that i've just made called
fave flavors it was uh let's say we run
an ice cream shop we asked our our
customers what their favorite flavor of
ice cream was
and
we got a bunch of different outputs
right chocolate vanilla strawberry a
bunch of vanilla's rocky road cookies
and cream but there's a lot of
duplicated values
now if i just run unique on this command
or on this file fave flavors
well that's weird it really doesn't seem
like it works because i see a lot of
duplicated values it seems like if it
only gives us unique values or you know
it removes duplicates we shouldn't see
cookies and cream twice we shouldn't see
vanilla twice or way more than twice
well what it does is it doesn't actually
just remove
all duplicated values instead
it removes adjacent duplicated values
and that might seem weird right
so we've got strawberry let's take a
look here chocolate vanilla strawberry
and then two vanillas
well if we look at the output from
unique we have chocolate vanilla
strawberry one vanilla
down here we had strawberry three times
in a row over here it shows up once in a
row when we use unique
so it is going to look at one line and
then the line after it and if it's the
same then it's only going to print out
one of those
so generally i use this in conjunction
with sort
so if i sort fave flavors and then pipe
that to let me just remind you what that
looks like
it's alphabetical so now they're all
chunked together right cooking cream
rocky road strawberry it's all together
and then i can pipe that to unique
and now we just get the unique values
because they were all in a row and the
way that unique works is it's only going
to take one uh anytime there's
duplicates in a row
but you might be thinking didn't we just
see there's a dash u option
and indeed there is a dash view option
for sort it kind of makes this obsolete
but there's additional behavior to the
unique command that can make it useful
for example if i do man unique there's
an option which is dash d
which will only print out the duplicates
so i only want the duplicates uh let's
try that let's do
well unfortunately they're all going to
be duplicates aren't they if i do this
dash d every single one of these flavors
appears more than once but if i echo how
about mint
into
fave flavors
and let's do one more flavor uh
how about uh pistachio or
um
how about rainbow sherbet
okay
so now we have two values that are not
unique
so if i remove that dash d
here is all of the sorted unique flavors
so we see a list of them but with dash d
now i only want the ones that are
duplicated
so we no longer have rainbow sherbet and
uh mint
side note i've always said sherbet my
entire life but uh i don't know i was
corrected on sherbet so now i'm
self-conscious some guess i'm sticking
with sherbet
um
so there's another option
instead of dash d
we can use the dash u option to display
non-duplicate lines so the lines that
only appear once
dash u
and now we can see oh these are the
flavors that uh only one person liked in
our case we've got mint and rainbow
sherbet everything else is duplicated so
we don't see it showing up
and then an even fancier option is that
we can get a count of how many times
each line appears with dash c
so why don't i do that here i'm going to
do sort all the flavors dot txt or fave
flavors and then pipe that to unique and
then dash c will give me a count and we
can see all right there's five
chocolates six vanillas one rainbow
sherbet and what's extra fun is that we
can actually take the output instead of
just printing it out i can re-sort that
numerically if i wanted to get a ranked
list because they all start with a
number i can do dash or sort dash n
so sort all the contents of that file
alphabetically which groups them all
together
then take that output and pass it to
unique which is going to weed out all
duplicated lines that are adjacent and
give us a count for how many times each
one appears but instead of printing that
out pipe that to the sort command again
where we will sort by number at the
beginning
and then we could even reverse it with r
and we can see the most popular flavor
vanilla so boring all the way down to
the least popular mint which is this is
not accurate i think mint is actually
quite popular but anyway
that is using piping along with the
unique commands kind of a lot to take in
so if you just need to sort the unique
values in a file you can do the dash u
option but if you want a count of how
many times uh different lines appear if
you want to weed out
duplicated values or you only want an
output that contains the values that are
duplicated you can use the unique
command
now if you remember when i introduced
the echo command if you happen to be
somebody watching this entire thing from
start to finish uh you may recall at
least when i introduced echo i talked
about
expansions and how
later on i would cover this thing called
expansions well that's what i want to
talk about now
what i'm about to show you is not
specific to the echo command but we'll
be using the echo command to help
illustrate uh how these expansions work
so when i say expansion what i mean is
that there are special characters and
special syntax that we can use with
various commands that the shell will
interpret and expand into some other
value
and probably the simplest example
is actually something we've seen before
the tilde
tilde expansion
if i just echo the character tilde tilde
has a special meaning i'll zoom in a
little bit as we've talked about it is a
shortcut that refers to
our home or my current user's home
directory so here
tilde is slash user slash cold steel now
when we echo it what we're actually
doing is asking the shell uh you know
print out tilde but it's not the
character tilde right if it's in quotes
then we get the tilde printed out what
it's doing instead is it's it's
expanding that character it has a
special meaning before it even runs the
echo command it's going to replace that
or expand it
to be this and that's what it echoes out
so when we do things like cd tilde
again the shell steps in and says oh i
know that let me expand that
and it turns it into slash user slash
cold steel
and that is where we see d2 so icd to
tilde it's the same end result
all right so there's other types of
expansion though including dollar sign
environment variable expansions so in
our shell there's a bunch of environment
variables available
some of the more common ones are things
like dollar sign
path
in all caps if i echo that
you'll see that it's been replaced with
a very long yours may be much longer
actually than this it's not too bad if i
run it over here on
ubuntu i think i have quite a long path
here nah not too bad either
so it takes this and it turns it into or
it expands it to the value of that
variable now if you don't know much
about environment variables don't worry
about it but here's one more example
user that's an environment variable for
the current username
okay
now a more useful thing
is path name expansion
so path name expansion allows me to use
special syntax special characters
to match different path names so we've
actually seen this before we just
haven't called it path name expansion
i'm in a directory right now well i'm in
my home directory aren't i so there's a
whole bunch of stuff here
different files and folders um why don't
i do this over on ubuntu because i have
some more files to work with okay
so when i type
echo i'm just going to use echo again
because it's an easy way to see what the
shell is doing for us so it's just going
to print back the expanded version of
the star character so if i wrap the star
character in quotes
that's what we actually get echoed back
but if i don't have those quotes and i
simply echo star
what i see is a list of every path name
in this current folder so every folder
every file name like you know
pokemon.txt word.txt
and then different folders like cleanup
and copies
i'm just matching everything so the star
means
every path here
but i can narrow it down and i can say
star
dot txt and we've seen this sort of
thing before
again this is going to then be replaced
with matching paths so this was replaced
with all of that
now if i do star.txt it's only going to
match something that starts with
anything but ends in exactly dot txt
okay and so here we are we see our
matches that end with txt
now echoing them may not be that useful
but i can do things like ls-l
star dot txt
i want to print out long listing
information about all text files in here
and there we go i only see txt files and
all their information so we also have
another character we can use to match
path names which is the dollar sign the
dollar sign the uh question mark uh a
question mark will match any single
character
so this would match any three characters
in a row
this would match any four characters in
a row so let me show you an example if i
echo
and i'll do anything
so a star matches anything and then a
dots and then any two characters
so this looks weird but it's saying
anything that must then end with a dot
and then exactly two characters i don't
care what those characters are but two
characters and oh we don't really match
anything do we in this folder i guess we
don't have any all right well let's try
three characters
and now we're just matching all our txt
files and zip files
it's not that exciting but just as an
example if i were to touch app.py and
you know app
dot
js and main.js
all right
and then i ran our original version here
which is anything
with a dots and then exactly two
characters now we're matching those dot
js and dot py extensions so i'm echoing
them again that's not what we would
normally do we might do something like
ls or we could even do rm if i want to
remove all those files this is kind of
very
dangerous and i don't know if i would
recommend this but just as an example
i could remove those files that have two
character extensions that would be a
very bizarre thing to want to do just
all two character extensions but i can
rm
star dot question mark question mark so
remove all files in here that end with
two character extensions
and i have it set up again automatically
to ask me
prompting me if i want to so
i will say
yes i'll remove all of them remove and
remove
all right so that's the basics of path
name expansion
next up we have some other types of
expansion so we'll start by talking
about curly brace expansion again i'll
use echo
when the shell encounters curly braces
and i provide a comma separated list of
values so i could do something like
let's just do letters to start
a b and c
okay if i just echo a b and c it's not
going to be very exciting but if i add
something before or after
let's do
abc dot
txt okay
what this is going to do is create every
combination of a followed by txt or dot
txt and then b and then c
and that's what we get a dot txt b dot
txt and c dot txt
so whatever these values are separated
by commas
i can create i can make files with them
if i wanted to the shell is going to
take this and expand it first so if i
did something like touch
and then how about um i did app dot
and then in curly braces js
html
css and py if i wanted to do that
i'll run it with echo first so you can
see what it would make me
app.js
app.html app.css app.py and then if i
wanted to actually create that
i could use touch
and that will make me all those files
so now there's a bunch of stuff here why
don't we narrow it down well only ls
things that end in two
characters or how about
app dot
and then
question mark question mark question
mark or how about a star all right and
so we can see what we created
we can also do numbers and provide
ranges so if i echo
1.99
this is going to be expanded to the
numbers between integers between 1 and
99.
so i could create a bunch of files
how about
day
and then let's do one to 365 if i was
keeping some sort of journal i'm not
making files right now i'm just echoing
it but the shell takes this it expands
it into this massive list of different
numbers or rather different
names day 94 day 95 and so on and then
i'm echoing it but i could just as
easily touch or make directory and
create 365 different directories in a
single line now there are other types of
expansion uh we're not going to spend
time talking about them but basically
the concept of expansion is that the
shell intervenes before a command runs
expands some smaller thing usually it's
small into a larger piece of text and
then passes that to some command and we
can use that to our advantage to craft
short commands that results in creating
hundreds of files or deleting a whole
bunch of stuff
or just matching a bunch of things by
defining a pattern like we saw
if we want to match you know anything
that how about starts with the letter f
and then ends in anything else
i'm just echoing it and this is just
echoing the paths that match this
pattern in my current directory
but then i could delete them all if for
some reason i didn't want them to start
with an f i could delete them all
or i could move them all i could copy
them there's a whole bunch of things we
can do next up we'll cover the diff
command which we can use to find the
differences between two different files
if you've ever used git you probably
have seen the get diff command
we will actually see
what it relies on behind the scenes to
generate a diff but first let's make two
files or at least one file that is
slightly different than another
so i have this ice cream flavor five you
know fave flavors file i'm going to copy
it
so copy fave flavors and i'm going to
make another file called fave flavors
2 dot txt it's not very original
all right so now we have two of them
and if i compare the two with diff at
the moment
they are identical
there's no difference so let's change
something in fave flavors two let's echo
another thing in there how about
what's another flavor well let's just do
mint again
and i'll append that
not with a single greater than sign two
i want to append to fave flavors
two dot txt
okay so now that exists at the end of
that file
just that one extra addition of mint
so if i rerun my diff between those two
files
this is what it tells me
24a25
mint now we could spend a lot of time
talking about how this works
but to read this change command here
what it's telling us is that
on the first file line 24
on the second file line 25 was added
so if we change the direction
if we instead compared fave flavors to
to flav fave flavors just on its own
now the output says line 25 on the first
file line 24 and the second file was i
don't know if the d stands for deleted i
believe
so you know appended added deleted
we can have multiple diffs too in a file
just
if i quickly change something in
how about
in fave flavors two so let's open that
up i'm gonna change something on line
three i'm gonna do strawberry
and
cream
all right i'm going to save that file
and close it
now if i do my diff between fave
flavors
and fave flavors two
we see we get two different diffs right
two different things that were changed
on line three of both files it was
changed from strawberry to strawberry
and cream
and then line 24 of the first file line
25 of the second file we added mint
anyway uh this is one way of using diff
but what's probably more common uh and
more useful is to see both files side by
side with dash y so that's one option if
we pass in dash y
uh although in this case um way zoomed
in it's kind of disastrous isn't it on
this screen size because i've tried to
make things readable
but if my font were quite small you
would see it side by side and then
lastly we have the dash u option which
is what git uses behind the scenes to
display its own diffs
and this just gives us a different
output if we look at mandif again and we
go down to dash u
output the num lines of unified context
so it gives us some context around each
change so let's do that again
instead of dash y dash u and what we see
here are the files that we're comparing
and then context is saying from line one
to six we can see what was added or
removed uh and then same thing here we
can see what was added so this is maybe
familiar if you use git and that's the
basics of the diff command next up we'll
talk about the find command so find
helps you find files or folders matching
some file pattern but there's quite a
bit to it and we could have a 20 minute
video at least devoted just to the find
command so i'm going to just try and hit
the highlights here
the first thing you should know is that
we can find
files and folders by a bunch of
different criteria we can find based off
of let's open up the man page
based off of the name of the file
the modification time uh the file size
the type if it's a file or a directory
or a sim link
there are probably many others that i'm
forgetting at the moment
and i'm just scrolling through the man
page here it's quite long as you can see
so again we're just going to hit the
some of the highlights here okay so the
first thing is if we want to find files
or directories we need to provide a
location to look inside of so find
inside of in this case dot meaning the
current folder or find in the desktop or
find in my
animals folder
and then we provide some sort of
criteria something to search against in
this case dash name
and then some sort of name that we want
to find
so i'm just going to search on my
desktop i have a bunch of files
but find will search recursively
so if i do a find dot and nothing else
just find dot
it is going to find every single file
nested somewhere inside my desktop
so there's a lot of stuff going on here
if i scroll i mean you can see they're
all nested
they're not actually on the desktop
they're nested multiple levels deep
uh we didn't specify any way of
narrowing what we're looking for but now
let's try let's find everything
that has
in its name and then instead of quotes
uh let's search for anything that has
hm
how about the number
seven in it
anywhere on my desktop or any folders
nested in the desktop or folders nested
in those folders and so on
really nothing
why didn't we find anything aren't there
at least there's one file here that has
a 7 in its name
and the answer here is that it's looking
for an exact match a file that has and
it is called seven if i made a file
called seven right here
and i reran it it would work we found
that file but what i want to do is find
any file on my desktop or nested
somewhere on the desktop that has the
number 7 in it
so this is where the special wildcard
characters
of a star in our case will come in a
star is just going to refer to anything
and then a 7 and then anything else
optionally before or after so if i do
this
we now get a bunch of matches a lot of
pokemon that i have for a different
video i made that have a seven in their
name somewhere but i'm sure there's some
non-pokemon here we go
morning day 27
nested very deep inside of this folder
or here's you know file 257
so we found files that contain seven in
their name
so if i wanted to find all files for a
particular type like all python files
dot py
i would put a star which again means
anything followed by
dot p y
and it looks like there's just one let's
try a dot j s
we've got a couple of js files
nested in my desktop now remember
dots is where i'm searching inside of
and that's just my current location but
i could instead say i want you to search
only within the stuff folder
if i can spell it correctly
it's not going to find anything but
maybe i'll find txt files
and there we go we only find txt files
inside of stuff
so we can also find by type i can find
directories or files or sim links so why
don't i do a find
on my desktop once again and all that i
want here
are
any entries anything that it finds where
type is d for directory now i forgot to
specify where to search we'll search in
our current directory and i get a list
uh these are all directories there's a
lot here
but no files if you notice none of the
actual files are present no dot txt or
js or whatever it's just the directories
if i did type f i only get the files as
you can see here these are all of course
they don't have extensions so you can't
tell but you have to trust me they are
all files
for each pokemon in this case or
whatever you're seeing printed out these
are all files there are no directories
that i've been found now there's
directories referenced in the path to
each file but that's not the same thing
as the actual directories being returned
as a result here
so we can combine them too maybe i want
to find directories only
so i'm going to do dash type is d
and name
as uh i don't know how about uh an
uppercase
um uppercase e
we'll see if we find anything that
contains an uppercase e and we do so
only directories somewhere on the
desktop
where in their name they have an
uppercase e so here we go uppercase e
uppercase these are all directories
now i can also do a case insensitive
version
if i do i name for insensitive
now i'm finding everything that has an e
it doesn't actually matter if it's
uppercase or lowercase so we see things
like right there there's an e in that
directory's name there's an uppercase e
and a lowercase e
okay
we can also do fancy logical things like
use the or operator so dash or so let's
give it a shot let's find uh
anything that has in its name so in our
current location
dash name it starts with the letter e so
actually sure let's do e
so e and then followed by anything now
remember
if we put a star there that means
anything can come before the e but what
i want is it must begin with the letter
in this case uppercase e so we get a
bunch of the e pokemon and there's some
others edgar ethel elvis instead of the
chickens directory
now if i also wanted to say
or name starts with
how about
f
star
and now i have fall
fungus
as well as espeon and you know files
that and directories that start with an
f or an e
uppercase only because i didn't do i
name
so that's just a taste of using the or
operator there's also a not operator
we can do things like search by file
size how many bytes
how many megabytes
greater than something so for example to
find files that are larger than 100
kilobytes but smaller than one megabyte
we could run this right here
so find where type is file f
and size is plus 100k greater than 100k
and size is minus
one m one megabyte so let's try an
example let's do uh find
where type is file and size is greater
than 100
kilobytes
and there we are
we get a list of files that are greater
than 100 kilobytes if i left that size
off we get way way more files
we can also do things around time so if
we want to find files that were edited
more than three days ago we would do
dash m time which is modified time plus
three and then we get to the last little
bit that i'm going to mention around
find
which is this weird looking thing dash
exec
this is an option we can provide where
we then specify a command that we want
find to run on each found result
so this example is going to find all
files in the current directory right
type is file
and on each one it is going to cat that
file out it prints its contents now i'm
not going to run that because on my
desktop i've got a million files that it
will print out
but let's talk about this quickly so
dash exec
is just the option saying hey i'm going
to give you a command i want you to run
with each match and then here's the
command the entire command we're
providing we do have to terminate it
with this backslash and then a semicolon
that is how the terminal knows where
that command ends and then this the
curly braces opening and closing is
going to be replaced it's a placeholder
it will be replaced with each found
result
so let's try an example let me recall
this line where we found files that were
larger than 100 kilobytes
we could verify the size of files one
way at least is with dash l ls l rather
right and we can see the file size here
and there's a lot of them
there's a couple that are larger but
most of them are pretty small
dash l is going to give us that long
listing so what i want to try is taking
these files that we find that are larger
than 100 100 kilobytes and then telling
find to then call ls-l
and then curly braces
and then we need our backslash semicolon
and
of course
my font is quite large here but what you
can see is that for each one of those
results if i just
run find without dash exec these are the
results right gg dot i think that's
great gatsby.txt
uh
pokemon exercise nano exercise whatever
these different files are they're all
here but we actually executed ls-l with
each one and we can see that file size
is large much much larger than the other
ones
we could do something instead like if we
wanted to cat each file out
but again there's going to be
quite a few
things printed out so all files larger
than 100 kilobytes
dash exec means i want you to then run
each match with cat
curly braces just concatenate them all
oh my goodness that's a lot of stuff
that was just printed out a lot of it is
kind of messed up but
there we are that is the result of
executing that cat command with every
single one of the found files that
matched with our find command
all right so there's a lot more to find
you can do some really powerful things
but that's just a quick intro next up
another command that could have its own
video for 20 30 minutes at least
grep there are many articles many
tutorials that are quite long that exist
solely to explain all the different
options and various ways of using grep
so what it does is it helps us find
text inside of files so the find command
helps us find files right based off of
their file name or different attributes
but it's not searching in the files
grep will search inside of files
so the simplest way to use it is to run
grip and then tell it some string or
some piece of text or something that
we're trying to find
and then a file to search inside of
so let me show you an example here let's
clear this screen all this craziness
i have this song of myself file
here i opened it in less there's a lot
of stuff in here and i want to find
every
time this file i don't know mentions
green in it so i can do grep
green
song of myself.txt
and it prints out to me the matches
right it highlights them in a different
color
of every time in this file the word
green showed up
so we've got green leaves green and
violet dusky green pale green eggs
quintillion's green
there we go we can also ask grep to give
us the line numbers with the dash n
option so we'll add that in right there
dash n
and now i'm getting the line numbers so
32 is the first one all the way to line
1026
i can also ask for some context if i use
an uppercase c
and then i provide an argument a number
of lines i want in this case two that
will give me two lines before and two
lines after each match so let's try that
c
and then two
and here we go
so this is one match this is actually
the last match on this line we have two
lines before and two lines after
uh here's another match right we have
two lines after two lines before
another option we can pass to grep is
dash r
which is for recursive uh and this is a
bit different this will actually tell
grep if i do grub dash r and then
provide some pattern like
chicken
it's going to tell it to search
recursively in my case right now just in
the current directory and all nested
subdirectories so instead of just
looking inside of one file like
hello.txt which doesn't exist
now i can look inside of all files at
least if i tell it a starting point i
think the default is just dot
okay so uh what we see here is a bunch
of matches
one from gg.txt or a couple a couple
from sorted everything and everything
feedstore.txt
website.html
greatgatsby.txt
so these are all files that were nested
somewhere in my desktop
and they all contained chicken
now uh it is important to note that it
is case sensitive so if i did you know
uppercase c no matches
but i can make it case insensitive with
dash i and now i get my matches again
now what makes grep really powerful is
that it can work with regular
expressions which i'm not going to go
over right now
if you know about regular expressions
you know the syntax you can provide
regex patterns to grep to search against
so you could find all matches of an
email pattern or a phone number pattern
and that sort of thing okay well i
changed my mind i'm going to show a
quick example i'm not going to explain
any of it
because regular expressions is its own
crazy topic but what i'm doing here is
using a pattern this is a regex that
will match email addresses so i'm
searching across recursively
across in my case the home directory
tilde
for any matches
to this email pattern
alright so i didn't type this out myself
just to be clear i found an email regex
but i'm going to run it
and
you'll see a bunch of different emails
that have been matched
being at search.mozilla.org
toolkit.mozilla.org
toolkit at mozilla again
firefox
these are all coming from some uh
documentation it looks like
from firefox here's some other ones
anyway the point is we can match these
patterns across uh in a file or across
our entire machine and there are tons of
powerful regular expressions that you
can write
but we're not going to talk about how
that works it's a whole separate topic
anyway that's a quick intro to crap next
up du disc utility
i think that's what it stands for i
guess i should verify
that would be the logical thing it
stands for
uh well
disk usage no i'm totally wrong i'm
pretty sure it's disk usage anyway
what we can do with du is find uh the
sizes of files and directories on our
machine
so if i just run du in my current
directory wherever i am
it's going to give me an output of all
the other directories in here and their
sizes so you can see
you know if i just pick one of these
let's find something slightly larger
here
sure
this
tar demo folder is 32 kilobytes
this wildlife folder is 16. this cleanup
directory is 156 kilobytes and so on
uh and then down at the very bottom i
can see my actual current folder right
here
is dots is 36 megabytes i can provide a
folder to look inside of instead of just
my current directory i could say
i want to know the pokemon exercise
folder
what's its size and it's uh let's see
24k
we can tell it to give us a different
format megabytes or gigabytes using dash
g for gigs dash m for megabytes so let's
do du
we'll do everything here dash m for
megabytes
uh it's all just one maybe two if i do
it on my mac here
we may get some more stuff
not a whole lot but some of this stuff
here's something 410 megabytes here's
something that's 25. now you may notice
it's not actually giving me uh the unit
it's just 1 or 0 or 10. if i use dash h
which is for human readable it now is
giving me a human readable size so 4k
24k but then also for some of these
larger things
we get you know gigs 5.7 gigs
so this is what i use most of the time
if i actually need to read something as
a human dash h
now here's kind of a nifty thing we can
do if i want to find the largest
directories on my desktop here i can do
d u dash h for human readable
okay
and i can pipe that to the sort command
now we're almost there it is sorting but
the way that it's sorting is not exactly
correct if you notice here
it's doing a sort you know once again
based off of the digits so it's saying
you know 9.2 m
megabytes is somehow smaller
than 900 kilobytes
so it's putting all the nines together
that's
that's a start but it's not actually
sorting them so sort actually gives us
an option if i go to man sort
it gives us an option dash h
oh where'd you go
i lost it here it is human numeric sort
so it sorts my numerical value but it
takes into account prefix or suffixes
like k or m or g
so it's for human readable numbers so
let's run this again we are going to get
a human readable format from du of all
the files on my desktop
sort them
with dash h to make it a human readable
sort instead of the default sort
and now
if we go to the top we get our smallest
files
the kilobytes and down at the bottom we
get our largest files and if i wanted to
find the top 10
largest files for example i could then
pipe that to tail that would be one
option and there we go i'm getting the
10 in this case because that's the
default for tail
largest or i could reverse
with dash r
and instead get the head which will be
the same thing right
i'm now getting the sort is in reverse
order and i'm taking the first 10
instead of the last 10. anyway that's an
intro to the d u command the next
command we'll see a nice and quick one
is df not to be confused with du
the du command showed us file sizes and
folder sizes whereas the df command will
tell us information about the mounted
file systems how much space they take up
and how much free space they have left
so i'll just show you very quickly here
if i run df with no arguments or options
i'm going to see
some output here yours will look
different
the file system so each individual file
system
and then the amount of size that it has
been allocated how much it uses how much
is available now this by default on
ubuntu is in one kilobyte blocks it's
not so easy to read if i switch
over and use the dash h option for human
readable
now we get megabytes and kilobytes and
gigs and that sort of thing
okay
so we can see things like
here is this file system udev
uh here's where it's mounted uh here's
how large how much space it's been
allocated and how much it's using
uh i'll show you this on my mac as well
so let's do that now i have to zoom out
quite a bit just so that we can see the
columns but what we'll see here is that
some file system uh has been allocated
up to
3.6 this is actually tip tebites
uh not terabytes uh
it's let's see it's a
1.1 times so 10 larger than a terabyte
and it really doesn't matter the thing
is i know this is a four terabyte
computer uh the drive here so three
point six terabytes makes sense anyway
that's how much space it's been
allocated but it's only using this file
system at least is only using 10 gigs
or you know here's another one this is
my slash dev disk 1s2 blah blah blah
blah
and here's where it's mounted it's also
has up to 3.6 tbytes to use but actually
it's used 2.2 terabytes out of that
anyway you may not really need to use
this command but i'm just being
comprehensive here one thing that can be
nice though is
if we pass a file or a folder as an
argument to df it will tell us more
information about the file system that
particular file or folder lives on
so if i wanted to know you know where's
my desktop and how much space is that
file system taking up i can do d let me
just clear first i can do df h for human
readable and then desktop
and we can see this is the file system
this is you know the capacity of that
file system how much is available and so
on
so that's all there is to df uh and
remember du tells us about the actual
sizes of individual files and
directories df tells us about i don't
know if it's disk free
or disk file systems or i don't know
what the f stands for i was trying to
look at the man pages and figure it out
but think of it as disk free sure next
up the history command now this one can
be very useful especially if you have
some long long commands you ran
i don't know 20 or 500 commands ago and
you want to rerun it and not have to
type it yourself again or you don't know
what it was that is what the history
command helps us with so on its own if
we just run history let's do it here on
my
linux machine so i'm going to run
history here
i'm going to get a bunch of lines as you
can see
there's a number next to each and then a
command that i ran so we can see a
history of all the commands that i've
run so history was the most recent
command before that i had man df and
then d u dash m i had clear i had d u d
u d u d u uh you know all these
different commands um and let's say this
is the command i want to rerun this is
the grep that will search for regular
expressions uh or sorry it searches for
emails using an email regular expression
across my entire machine
i don't want to have to type this myself
one option i guess it's just to copy and
paste that definitely but there's also
something called history expansion where
if i have that number and your numbers
are going to be different but if i have
a number
i can take it and simply run exclamation
points and then that number 2064
and now it's running that command again
it's finding all these matching emails
across my machine
so
just one more example oh geez i need to
rerun history
and if you prefer you can actually pipe
this
to less
so that command less opens up a program
where we can scroll a bit easier we can
page through commands one at a time
i can find some command like
i'm sure this one here
that finds
things that start with the letter e or f
so it's 20 40. i can exit less and just
run exclamation point 2040 and now it
finds me all the files and directories
that have an e or an f uppercase as
their first letter another thing you can
do is actually combine
grep with uh history if you're trying to
find some commands you ran a long time
ago you know as you probably just saw
there's tons of commands here and
somewhere in this massive list my
history list
there was a command i ran and i know
that it included the word i don't know
cookie but i'm not sure where it is and
i want to rerun that well i can run
history and then pipe that to grep
remember pipe that pipe character allows
us to take the output of one command and
pass it as input to another so then i
can search for
cookie
and there's quite a few actually
surprisingly
where there are commands so we're just
searching through the text returned from
history using grep we found a match five
or what six seven different matches and
if i want to run one of these i can take
that number and exclamation point that
number
so 1686
this is just going to make me a bunch of
files so i even want to do that
not really but i've already committed
okay
so you can see it made me those files i
think it was cake and cookie and there's
cookie
cake is up here somewhere anyway that
can be quite useful if you know
somewhere in this massive history there
was some command and it included some
pattern or some some word and that's all
you remember well you can use grep to
search for it the next command we'll
cover is ps
so ps is a command that helps us inspect
or view the process processes processes
running on our computer
so if we take a look at man ps
process status is what it stands for i
didn't actually know that i just always
thought of process in my head anyway
it's going to display information about
currently running processes processes
and by default if we just run ps i'm on
my mac in this example with no other
options or arguments it shows me a list
of all the processes started uh by me
the current user
so uh what we see here we've got uh well
first of all
the process id we've got the time we've
got the actual command
you can see i've got a bunch of bash
shells and uh and then really the only
somewhat interesting thing i guess would
be this python process i have uh i have
a python server in a different tab that
i've started but just to show an example
i'm gonna start a node server in this
tab i've got this app.js i'm going to
run it with node here's my server it's
running i started a new process
now if i run ps again
we see
somewhere there we are that process
right there
okay so that is a process i started and
we can see it right in this list it has
an id
and in a moment we'll also learn how we
can kill a process where that id can
come in handy
but there's more to this command we can
also view a list of processes initiated
by anyone on our machine basically all
the processes
not just the ones that are user
initiated by me
so all
processes to do that p s
a x
so this is a pretty common one v s a x
we're going to see a lot more going on
here
so we still have you know that node
server i started up we've got our bash
instances and then a whole bunch of
system stuff look at all these processes
now you will see they get cut off here
so if they don't wrap over to the next
line i can't scroll it just gets cut off
so there's a way around that
it's a very weird option if we add on
two w's a x w w
now you'll see that they wrap around
so i've got my short processes that i
initiated here but then some of these
are quite long
like this google chrome helper renderer
i mean it goes all the way down to what
about there i think
no actually here i mean that that's very
long but it does wrap over instead of
being cut off
so something that can be very helpful is
to combine grep with the ps command so
that you can find some process and
generally when you're trying to find a
process at least when i'm trying to find
something i actually might be trying to
kill it which is again a command we'll
learn shortly
so there's this massive list and
somewhere in here i do think i have
visual studio code open but i don't know
what its process id is
that's this first column here i could
search though so i can recall that
command
and then pipe it to grep and let's just
look for visual to start
alright well there's quite a few of
those how about visual studio
okay so here are all the matches for the
visual studio code processes
quite a few still wow all right didn't
narrow it down all that much
but here this is the one we'd probably
want to kill the visual studio code.app
now i wouldn't actually kill visual
studio code this way you can just quit
it or force quit it but when i cover
kill just in a moment you'll see that
there are some situations where you
would need to do this you actually would
need to find out the process id
all right so that's a quick intro to ps
there's a lot more to it
as you can see there's some options we
didn't really cover any of these
you can filter processes by who they
belong to or who started them you can
change the display format you can add
more information to be displayed anyway
there's a lot more you can do but the
basic concept is that it displays
information about the processes running
on your machine the next command we'll
take a look at is top top
i actually
don't know what that stands for
does it tell us not really it says
display and update sorted information
about processes i think
it comes from the fact that it will show
us the top
most
memory intensive processes or the top
most cpu intensive processes
so what it does if we just run top
it's going to open up
sort of a different screen we don't see
our prompt anymore
what we see now is a little dashboard
that shows us information by default of
the top
that must be where it comes from the top
most uh cpu intensive processes so you
can see over here the command
so i've got screenflow that's what i'm
using to record this video
i've got uh some core audio
terminal the top
command itself they each have a process
id
we can see a bunch of other information
the memory that they're taking up
the cpu percentage
and we can also
sort instead by memory so if i rerun
this it's dash o
m e m for memory
and you'll see now this is highlighted
and we can see they are sorted in order
of how much memory these processes take
up processes so chrome unsurprisingly is
up top and then i've got uh
these are i'm using parallels for my
virtual machines i have windows running
over here and then i've got uh linux
running over here so that's what you see
there
i've got chrome again uh pdf editor
the screenflow um anyway it doesn't
really matter but what you'll see is
different but we can sort things by the
amount of memory they take up
and we can see that process id which is
useful when we want to kill something
later on uh you need to reference that
process id all right so that's top to
get out of here type q
that's the easiest way i think you can
also get out with control c most likely
yeah i just use q the next command we'll
cover is kill k-i-l-l
we use this command to kill programs but
it's actually a little bit more
complicated than that it's not just a
matter of saying shut this thing down or
kill it
there are a whole bunch of different
different types of signals that we can
send when we run the kill program
so there's actually a lot of different
signals and it can be very overwhelming
and confusing if you try and understand
them all i'll just quickly show you here
if we run the kill command with dash l
it's not going to kill anything it
instead will list the different signals
that we can send
so there's things uh actually to make
this a bit easier why don't we pipe that
to less so i can scroll through it all
right so we've got things like
sig int and sig il and sig kill sig bus
sig term
sig charm is actually a pretty common
one it's terminate
we've got say kill signal kill
let's see there's a whole bunch of these
the vast vast majority i've never ever
had to use
and they all are supposed to be
different they are supposed to do
different things
but what's confusing is that it's
actually up to the specific program that
you're trying to kill it's up to that
program source code to handle these
different signals
okay so let's talk about some of the
most common signals
and the basic syntax essentially the way
that we kill something is by using the
process id we saw how we can use
commands like ps
and top to find a process id
and then we specify a signal so
we can specify a signal using the long
form a word
so
hup that's a common one means hang up
we can send you know term to terminate
that's the default but what i prefer to
do and what a lot of people do is
instead you can use a number so as we
saw here there's a number corresponding
to each one of these signals so if i go
back
as i said term is a common one the
number there is 15.
kill is nine so we could send that
signal too all right so
if you're wondering what does this all
mean when would i use one versus the
other the way that i think about it um
is that in general i try and use 15
first this is the gentlest way to quit
something or to stop a process think
about with the graphical user interface
the different ways of of quitting or of
shutting something down
one option is to uh just quit your
application and save your changes
another is to quit and click don't save
another option is to
force quit the entire application
another option is to
unplug your computer these all are
different ways of of quitting or
shutting down a piece of software
and that's kind of a silly version uh
but the idea is that there are these
different signals so 15 or sig term is a
gentler way to quit
it basically the idea is that your
program that you're quitting or killing
would have time to
tie up any loose ends save any necessary
state whereas on the complete other end
of the spectrum we have nine which is
what a lot of people use so a lot of the
tutorials and docs you'll see just says
to use nine which is the most brutal way
of just shutting everything down and
basically just force quitting a program
and then there's a whole bunch of stuff
in between but i like to try and start
with 15 that allows things to shut down
how they would normally and if that
doesn't work then we use 9 which is just
pulling the plug on the life support for
that program all right so let's see how
it works so just like a burgeoning
serial killer we need to find our first
thing to kill so fortunately i have a
couple of node processes that i want to
stop i want to kill
if i do ps a here
i have a server running uh two actual
node servers uh here's the process id if
we'll just take that first one and i
wanna kill it so i'm gonna copy that id
and it turns out that
you know i can't stop this any other way
normally you start a server and then you
can stop it with control c or something
but i've lost that window
i don't have access to just type control
c to quit the server so i need to kill
it this way
okay so i have the process id now the
syntax is kill
and then i can provide either a number
like if i'm doing nine that is the
brutal way of killing something that's
the the just immediately kill
we can provide the
name
kill or even the full name sig kill
but i'm going to start with the default
so if i just kill and then i put the
process id in there this will send a
term terminate signal that's the gentler
way first that's the default so this is
a gentle way that gives it time to close
up shop and save its state if needed so
if i try that i don't get any feedback
and if i do psa again
it's still there
so it didn't seem like it worked just
give it a couple of seconds sometimes we
will just double check come back nope
it's not working
so now it's time for more aggressive
action
we're going to provide a signal and
remember we can list all those signals
if i do kill dash l
this isn't that helpful to be honest uh
it i mean it gives us a list but what
does this mean
what i generally stick with and by far
the most common if you are gonna pass
one through is nine but remember that's
a brutal one nine is the kill signal and
that's the one that just pulls the plug
so we can pass that in
kill let me just clear
dash nine
and why didn't i just show you it is
here right there's that process
kill dash nine and then the process id
okay once again no feedback whatsoever
psa and now it's gone now we just have
this other node server running
okay so that's the basics of the kill
command i know it can be a little
overwhelming
but the idea is that you provide some
signal and then a process id and that
signal will be sent to some usually kill
or terminate or do something
to end that process next up in our
killing arsenal is the kill all command
so kill all
is different from the kill command in
that we actually can provide a name
instead of a process id we can provide
the name of a program that we want to
kill
and if we have multiple it will kill
them all
uh so if i happened just
maybe happen to have multiple node
servers running once again
i actually just have them here so here's
one
and here's the other um
i could just you know ctrl c and quit
them nice and easy but let's just say i
can't uh so i want to kill both of them
instead of doing the process ids and all
of this i can just do kill all and then
provide a signal just like before with
regular kill i can do kill or sig kill
or nine and this is the most violent way
of killing something
kill all dash nine and then
node so that is the name of the program
i wanna kill
once again no feedback unfortunately but
let's see what happens
well i don't see any node processes here
and if i go to my terminal windows oh
killed
and killed
so that is the basic use of the kill all
command it doesn't require process id
it's definitely less precise generally i
use kill because i can isolate exactly
what i want to kill but if i know
there's multiple things or i just it's a
pain to find the process id then you can
use kill all next up we're going to talk
about three commands that go together
jobs
j-o-b-s
vg for background and fg for foreground
so these three work in conjunction and
they all have to do with running things
in the background and well in the
foreground
so if we have some command or a program
that happens to take a long time for
example a command like this where i'm
using find
in the root directory so on the entire
machine find all files that have changed
in the last one day 24 hours
so there's a lot of system files and a
whole bunch of stuff it's going to take
a long time if i just run it right now
i'm going to get a bunch of permission
issues but it's still running if you
look down here
it's going
and it's going to take quite a while to
check every single file on my machine
so it's running in the foreground right
now right meaning i can interact with it
it's not well happening in the
background um so i can stop it right if
i do control c
that just stops the whole thing
um and there's actually something else i
can do
if i run control z what i can do is
suspend it which kind of puts it in a
state of uh well suspension it's not
stopping it entirely forever it's not
ending it it's pausing it so i'm gonna
rerun that
and by the way what i'm doing here is
finding all those files and then putting
it all eventually in a file called all
changes or all maybe i should rename
that to be all changed files or whatever
we're not going to be using this to do
anything i just am using it to
illustrate that we can have these things
that take forever
so if i hit control z
right now
you'll see it says stops right here so
this is slightly different than what
happened earlier
and now if i type the jobs command which
is how we can check up on any jobs we
have running
we see this program
is currently stopped
okay so let's try doing something else
what about uh the top command if you
remember this it's going to show me all
these different processes on my machine
and how much memory and all the stuff
they're taking up
and i can use control z to stop this as
well so ctrl c just gets me out of there
if i do control z
it actually stops that or pauses it and
if i type the jobs command again now we
have two jobs in here
so two different jobs
that are both control z they're both
suspended
now what i can do is selectively
re-run or resume one or both of these
jobs in the foreground like what we saw
here is in the foreground
or i can actually run them in the
background so that they they keep going
but i won't see all this text i won't
see them in my terminal but they'll
still be running
so this jobs command is just how we
check up on jobs see what their state is
and they also have
an id or a job number and that's
important because when we want to
selectively resume them we can use those
numbers
all right so the first command i'm going
to show you after jobs is actually fg
for foreground
so if we run foreground and then we
specify a number a job number
that job will be resumed so if i want to
resume the top command its number is 2.
so if i do fg
2 there we go
it is now running again and it's in the
foreground
so i could suspend it with ctrl z or i
can just get out of here control c or q
if i look at jobs now we just have this
one job right this is my find program
now i can resume this in the foreground
by doing fg
and then the number one
or because it's the only job i could
just type fg
so i'm going to do that now
and here we are it's resumed again in
the foreground it's just going to take
forever and maybe we'll get some
permission denied stuff
let's see if there's any text
and if i grow tired of this i want it to
run in the background i don't want to
see all this taking up my terminal
screen i want it in the background not
the foreground i can suspend it
and
go back to jobs
it's suspended
i can resume it but instead of doing
foreground one
i can do background one whoops
and that will resume it it will be
running but i'm not gonna see it running
so i'm gonna do that
so it gives me a little message saying
all right this is running and it's in
the background and the way that we know
it's in the background there's two ways
one this ampersand means something is
running in the background two if i type
jobs
it's telling me right here running
so it is running but we don't see it
running right we don't see all that text
but by using the jobs command we can
verify it is indeed running
i could bring it back to the foreground
if i wanted to you know foreground
i don't have to specify one it's the
only job and here it is it's in the
foreground
and that's really all that there is to
this
we can run things in the foreground in
the background and we can use the jobs
command to check up on them
this is going to just take forever let's
see if it ever finished i'm just going
to quit or stop it uh let's look at our
all changes file
yep so it's got a lot of stuff in there
and let me just prove this to you one
more time that it does work so i'm going
to remove that all changes file
yep
all right so now we no longer have that
all changes file if you remember i said
the ampersand is one way we can send a
job to the background uh so here's
another a very stupid program in this
context uh sleep
is uh just going to stop if i just run
sleep five i'll just show you the man
page this is a new command it just
delays for a number of seconds so five
seconds i won't do that long let's do uh
sleep two seconds
so you'll see nothing happens it's a
delay for two seconds and then my prompt
comes back so we can use this if we're
writing a script or something where we
need to stop to wait for
uh data to come back or to wait for
to make a user feel like something is
taking longer than it actually is for
better ui there's all these different
uses but typically i don't run sleep
unless i'm teaching it
now i can run this in the background so
let's do a long sleep like
50 seconds
so if i ran this in the foreground again
it's stupid to do this but if i did i'm
waiting here for 50 seconds um and i
can't do anything else so i'm going to
control c and end that but if i run it
in the background which i can do by just
adding an ampersand so sleep for 50
seconds in the background that's what
the ampersand at the end means
now i don't see that happening here if i
look at jobs
it is running though it is a job it's
running in the background
and then i could bring it back to the
foreground if i wanted to just like that
and now it's running in the foreground
all right uh so i'm just gonna stop it
anyway and if i go back to jobs now
there's no jobs all right so that's kind
of a lot of stuff around
jobs and foreground and background
let's just recap that so if you have a
program you run a command put an
ampersand at the end
it's going to run in the background if
we don't do that but we want it to run
in the background i say after the fact
let's rerun my find command this long
find command i could run it
and then
suspend it
and then decide i want that to run in
the background so i could get the job id
i happen to know there's only one job
but i could get that id and now say go
in the background one
and now it's running in the background
and it will take a while eventually it
will complete
it's still running as we can see here it
has that ampersand it shows us it's
happening in the background
i don't know how long it's going to take
quite a long time but eventually it will
finish
next up we're going to talk about
compressing files
we'll first talk about the gzip command
which is used to compress files
it uses an algorithm called gzip there
are multiple different compression
algorithms if we take a look at gzip on
the man pages
it the whole idea is that it reduces the
size of files using
lenthil ziv coding lz77
so you know compressing is a very
complicated um interesting but very
complicated
area of study and there are quite a few
different algorithms
but one of the most common on linux at
least is gzip so the way that it works
is that we have some file hopefully a
larger file that we're trying to reduce
the size of
and we provide it to gzip however i
would warn you it's not a huge deal but
if you just run gzip with a file name it
is going to take that original file
compress it and replace the original
file so you'll only have the compressed
version that ends in gz
that's just the extension that it gives
it uh if you want to keep the original
file you can do two different things
this is a slightly clunkier way but the
better option in my opinion is to use
dash k
i don't know if it stands for dash keep
that's what i think in my head
and that will keep the original file so
let me just demonstrate this here i've
got a somewhat large text file if i just
uh cat it out it's a lot of stuff in
there it's the result of running a find
command and redirecting the output into
this file okay so if i run gzip and i'll
do dash k
on that file
we don't get any output which i'll show
you how to correct in just a moment if
you want some output but if i type ls
we now have
this file here all changes.txt so the
same name but now it has an
additional.gz.gzip extension
if i do an ls-l
we can see the file
size difference but actually let's make
it human readable with lh for human
readable
pretty significant
reduction in size almost 2 megabytes
down to 200 kilobytes
now i'm going to remove that
so remove all changes.txt
and uh i'm going to just show one more
oh no
i removed the wrong thing
well that's annoying all right
it's gone i don't have that original
file if you remember when i talked about
remove
when you remove it doesn't go to a
temporary recycling bin it is gone but
the good news is we do have the
zipped file the gzip compressed version
and i can unzip that to get my file back
so we'll just jump ahead and talk about
unzipping so the way that we can do that
is to use the dash
d option to decompress that is one way
of doing it
and then there's also a totally separate
command called g unzip which you can use
which is basically the exact same thing
there's a couple more options but it
will unzip a gzip compressed file in the
same way that gzip dash d will unzip
so let's start with uh well why don't we
do g unzip
all
changes.txt.gz
all right i type ls and there we are i
now have the uncompressed if we do ls-l
let's do lh
1.8 megabyte version
okay
so let me just show one more thing when
we g-zip it again so i have that
original i want to keep the original and
if i add dash v for verbose it's going
to give me information about
how much space it reduced or how much it
compressed the file
all right so i'm going to do gzip dash
kv and then
my file is all changes.txt
and it says it reduced it by almost 87
if we do lh for ls
we can see once again 1.8 m
232k so a lot smaller and then just one
more time we can use g unzip
or we can do gzip dash d
for decompress
on that file
and it's going to ask me if i want to
overwrite
because what i'm doing here right i kept
the original so i would be unzipping
a new file with the exact same name do i
want to replace it sure
okay
and now
we're back to what we were at before
it is well let's do h again 1.8
megabytes so i unzipped
and that's kind of all that there is to
that one thing that's important to know
about gzip is that it will only zip
individual files so it won't you know it
won't take 10 files and zip them
together into a single compressed file
we'll see how to do that with a
different command
but just to show you what happens if i
make let's see i have this one file
let's make another file whoops
just with some very small text in there
i'll call this one.txt
and let's do it again actually for 2.txt
okay so i now have three files in here
if i do gzip and i'll do dash k if i
want to keep the originals sure
g g zip dash k and then
we'll do v as well for verbose all
changes and then a space
one and two i can provide multiple files
and it does compress them but it
compresses them individually so we end
up with
three different gzip files
okay so it did not combine them it just
compressed multiple
so that brings us to our next command
tar tar tar is a command that we use to
create an archive which is basically a
grouping of a bunch of files potentially
a bunch of files together into a single
file and then we can go and compress
that file so the name tar is short i
think for tape archive an older
relic of uh days gone by
but anyway the way that it works is it's
kind of complicated there's a lot of
options the man page if i just go to
mantar it's very long lots of options
but i'm just going to show you some of
the most basic things that you might
want to do primarily taking a folder
full of a bunch of files and combining
them down into a archive and then
compressing that so that we have a
single file that is compressed that we
can then unzip later and then expand
back into a whole bunch of files
okay so the syntax the basic syntax is
to run tar
and then a couple of options to create a
new archive
to smush files together
we provide the different files we want
to smush together separated by spaces
we provide two options c for create and
then f is it's the way we provide the
file name that we want it to create so
if we provide f we must provide the
archive name unlike when we zip a single
file it can you know gzip can just use
the name of that file and append gz but
here we're combining files together so
we need to provide an end result name
okay
so i have
a simple oops
let me go into that folder a simple
folder here
ls-lh shows us we've got three files
lots of text more text and song of
myself.txt
i'm going to combine the three of these
into a new archive so the way that i do
that is tar
c for create f
is the file option so i provide the file
name for the archive i'm going to call
it
um
i don't know archive okay
and conventionally these end with dot
tar as the extension
and then we'll just provide the file so
song of myself
what was it lots of text more text and
then i'll hit enter and this will create
a new archive file as you can see right
there
and this does not mean it's compressed
to be clear
okay it's just a single file if you look
at the file sizes 3.6 megabytes well we
had 1.8 1.8 and then 85 kilobytes so we
did not lose any size along the way this
is not compressed but now i could go and
compress this if i wanted to
but before we do that let me show you
how we can un-archive to extract files
from an archive we use the dash x option
for extract
c was to create x is for extract
and if we just do x f and then we need
to provide the file name once again this
would be the archive we just created
this will unarchive it in our current
folder but we can also move them so we
can provide a directory a destination
with dash c
and before that we can actually just
view what's in the file if we use the
dash t option
so i can just show you that
why don't i move my archive somewhere
else let's move um why don't i just make
a new directory i'll just call this
somewhere
and then i'll move my archive into
somewhere
okay so let's cd into somewhere all
right so now i can show that dash t
option which we can use to view the
files uh that are inside of this archive
so we have this let's just say i
downloaded it i don't know what's in it
well i can do a tar
t
f archive
there we go it says hey there's three
files in here
i don't have them they're not
out of that archive they're still in
there all combined down into a single
file but i can then extract them i'll
just do it in the current directory
so to do that it is tar
x f and then the archive
now i have those three files as you can
see here
okay and then again i could provide a
destination instead if i want to extract
them somewhere else with dash uppercase
c
okay so still no compression the next
step is to combine compression gzip is
going to be our algorithm along with
archiving with tar
so we can do this separately just to be
clear i could do
if i uh just remove
lots of text more text and song of
myself
yes yes yes okay
so i have this empty directory except
for the tar i can compress that tar as
we saw with gzip so gzip and then i'll
do dash k to keep the original file if i
want to
archive.tar
and now i have the compressed version
okay so it's only 502 kilobytes compared
to 3.6 megabytes
so let's delete the original tar so
rmarchive.tar
and now i just have the compressed
archive so this is really you know a
bunch of files combined down into a
single archive then compressed this
might be something we download or
something we get from some mysterious
source now i want to get it back to the
original files that are inside of it so
i need to uncompress and then i need to
unarchive
so to uncompress or decompress remember
we use gzip
and then dash d
and then the name of the file
so now i just have the regular archive
it's much larger right 3.6 megabytes
now i need to uh on archive so we need
tar.
x for extract
f so we provide the file which is
archive.tar
and there we are we get our original
stuff back out
okay so we can do it in two different
steps like we did there make the archive
then compress and then uncompress go in
the other direction uncompress and then
unarchive or we can actually use just
the tar command to do it all together
the tar command
has a special option z for gzip which
will also compress and archive with that
gzip algorithm at the same time
so instead of two separate steps we can
do it at once so i'll just show that
real quick
let's do the same thing
let's remove my archive i have my three
files i'm going to combine them together
with tar
i'm going to do create i'm going to zip
with
gzip and then i'm going to do f so i can
provide the file name we'll call this
bundle this time dot
tar and then space the files i want
okay
and take a look at what we get
i should have probably named it with a
dot gz extension but if we look at the
bundle.tar
it is compressed it's much smaller so
you don't have to have that extension
but you want that there if somebody else
sees it
so they know you know this is a gzip
file
and you need to use g unzip
to unzip it so if i want to remove these
files so we just have the single archive
or the bundle file
okay
there we are now to unzip it and
unarchive i can just run our regular old
tar
x for extract f provide the file name
i don't even have to tell it to use g
unzip so let's try it there it is
remember it looks like this 500
kilobytes single file
i'm going to do atar
extract and the file name is bundle.tar
and let's see what we get
there we are we got the three files back
out all right so we saw two ways of
doing it first we can create a bundle or
create a tarball and then compress that
or we can do it all in one go if we have
multiple files we want to combine and
compress we can provide the dash z
option as we saw here to create a gzip
compressed file next up we'll talk about
a fun command called nano n-a-n-o
nano is actually a text editor you can
run directly from your terminal now
there are other text editors some that
are quite a bit more powerful
than nano
but they are also quite a bit more
complicated to learn and when you're
starting out you can really mess things
up so things like vim if you've ever
heard of vim
powerful but really tricky to learn when
you're starting out and also could have
its own hour long video there actually
are courses on just using it so we're
not going to go into that but nano is
another editor that comes built in that
we can use and the reason it's good to
know one of these editors at least and
there are others there's emacs and the
reason it's good to know them is that
you can directly very quickly change
files or make modifications add things
onto files
without having to go through the whole
process of opening up an external
graphical editor you know you can do
things quickly
so i don't use something like nano as my
main editor i like using vs code or
something similar but it doesn't mean
you shouldn't know how to use it now the
basic usage is nano
followed by some file name we want to
edit
so what do we have here i've got a song
of myself
txt
i'm going to open that up with nano so
this is a file we've been using quite a
bit throughout the course and when i hit
enter you'll see that my prompt goes
away i'm now in an editor i can use the
arrow keys to move and i can actually
immediately start editing and this is
different if you ever have encountered
vim if you start typing
you're not actually going to be editing
things immediately there's all these
different modes and you might be messing
things up significantly but i can start
typing so if i want you know i can say
hello there
and
i can use my arrow keys left and right
just like a regular cursor up and down
um
and let's just start with that i'll make
a little change there
all right so i've made this change
now i want to save this
this is probably the most important part
of working with nano is down at the very
bottom
down here
is kind of a little toolbar
this is a list of shortcuts the
different commands we can use inside of
nano and one of the most important ones
is
this right here control x this is how we
can exit
so if i do control x right now
first it's going to ask me before you go
do you want to save or not
i'll save that change so i'll hit y
if i don't want to save it i'll type n
and if i don't want to quit i can do
control c
okay so i'm going to hit y to save
and then it's going to ask me well do
you want to keep the same file name do
you want to make a new file name uh you
know save it somewhere else i'm just
going to hit enter and keep the original
file so i'm just saving a new version of
song of myself instead of a copy
all right
so it's still there and how do i take a
look at the beginning of the file i just
want to see if it changed head song of
myself
there it is we did successfully make a
change
now there's more that we can do so i'm
going to reopen that file
in nano
and a couple of things first of all if
you notice on the right side here uh i'm
getting a little angle bracket uh
greater than sign that is telling us
that there's more text
so you can actually turn word wrapping
on or line wrapping if you prefer for it
to wrap over
but i think the default is for it to
just scroll as you see there
we have different shortcuts
down here so if we wanted to search for
example
to find something in this file i can do
control w all right so control w and
then i can provide something i want to
look for so
i want to change the word green in this
file so i'm going to type green and i'll
hit enter
and
my cursor shows up right there on the
first match of green
now i can keep searching again if i do
ctrl w and hit enter again see it
already remembers green
it takes me to the next match so let's
just make this all caps
and very long green
all right
uh i'll save and as we saw previously
one way of doing that is by quitting and
it will prompt me do you want to save
blah blah blah
but if i don't want to quit and i just
want to save my changes i actually do
have ctrl s
so i just did it it doesn't show up down
here
there's far more options that don't show
up down here
i'll show you how to view them in a
moment but ctrl s does save to the
current file right it's not making a new
file name it doesn't give you an option
do you want to save this somewhere else
it just saves
to the same name okay
so if i type ctrl g right here
get help
i wish it was ctrl h ctrl g is harder to
remember
we get a whole manual here
that explains how it works and then
explains all the different shortcuts so
there's quite a few things in here
we saw ctrl w to search forward
we can actually insert another file into
this file or into this buffer with ctrl
r
we can cut and paste so this is one that
you know you've probably noticed control
c
uh and control v for copy and paste
don't really work in the terminal
control c has its own meaning uh
just like control z has its own meaning
to suspend a job anyway uh we still can
cut and paste the way that we can do it
is with ctrl k to cut
it actually stands for kill
and then u
to revive or to unkill i don't know what
the u stands for
and that will
basically take whatever we've cut out
and paste it so i can show you that
there's options to configure a spell
checker
we can display line numbers we can go to
a particular line number if we know what
we want with uh where's that
control underscore
there's a bunch more stuff so you know
this is not a course on nano but just so
you know there's a lot to nano
okay so to get out of here ctrl x is
going to close the help screen
now as i said i want to show you cutting
and pasting so if i want to cut a line
i guess maybe i'll just type a line
first
hi there
cut me out of here please
all right if i do ctrl k
it's gone
and then i can move it down somewhere
maybe here and ctrl u
it revives it and i keep hitting ctrl u
there we go
it's just like cut and paste uh if you
do forget about that we can see
shortcuts down here
okay so i'm going to save control s we
also can do control o to write out if i
wanted to create a copy or a different
file name i could type that here so
maybe uh you know song of myself 2 dot
txt and this is my version
i'll hit enter do i want to save it
under a different name sure
and then i'll get out of here ctrl x
one more thing i'll show you you can
actually create a new file with nano so
if i need to add some text into
something
a file that doesn't exist i don't have
to make the empty file first then open
it with nano i can just do nano new file
dot txt
and now i have an empty file i can type
my stuff in here
save and quit
control s control x and there it is
song of myself too from the previous
nano and then uh new file.txt
okay
next up we have the alias command the
alias command allows us to define our
own aliases our own our own little short
custom commands
that we can then reuse later on so for
example if we find ourselves doing you
know ls
remember just gives us this information
ls-a
gives us all including hidden files
ls-la
gives us listed long format information
for all files
if we find ourselves doing that a lot we
could set up our own alias so that we
don't have to type all of that and maybe
just have la
for example
so if we wanted to do that i want la to
actually be ls-la
the way that we do that is by using the
alias command
so i'll show an example here i'm going
to do alias
and then
let's just call this my i'm gonna do
something really obvious first like uh
my ls
equals and then in quotes i'm gonna use
single quotes there's a distinction here
uh single quotes and then i'll do ls
dash
la just like that
okay
so if i type alias now
i'm gonna see a list of all my aliases i
actually have quite a few on here here's
the one i just made
already and if i try running it my
ls there we go i have a new alias
i could take something you know really
long like if there's some find command
that i use a lot
let me just show an example here
i think i have yeah like this one right
here this finds some of the i think it's
the top 10 uh most uh cpu intensive
processes on my machine um honestly i
never use it because i don't even
remember this
but if i run that it's a very long
command relatively long
i can alias it to something short so
pscpu10
and there we are i need to sort of zoom
out my font size is too large for me to
make sense of this here but that's all
right i'm recording i need that large
font size the alias we just defined is
not permanent if i close this window or
even just open another window
my ls
huh
it's not working
it doesn't know what the heck i'm
talking about so when i just define an
alias like bobo right here
equals
i don't know how about just sleep for 10
seconds
okay
when i define that in my shell directly
here
it only exists in this exact instance
right here
it is not going to be created every time
i open up a new terminal window or my
computer restarts i lose it
so if i want to make an alias last if i
want to have it persist i need to put it
in one of a couple different places
it depends on what shell you're using if
you're using bash if you're using z
shell
there are different configuration files
now
over here i'm using bash this is ubuntu
the default shell is bash
and if i go to my home directory it's
actually where i am right now again home
meaning my home folder not the folder
actually called home it's confusing but
my user's home folder colt um if i do ls
dash a
there are some of these special config
files now there's actually on ubuntu
there's one called bash aliases and that
is a good place to put aliases however
that is particular to some distributions
of linux it is not something that you
may not see it depending on what distro
you're using
so a safe place is going to be the bash
rc file so it's hidden
rc uh and i can open it up i'll use nano
to edit it dot bash rc
okay now i'm in nano i can scroll down
and i can define my own aliases in here
um so let's just i think i already have
some here there we are
uh so i'll just define some in here just
as an example uh alias
and i'm just going to write the exact
same thing that i wrote earlier
except i'm putting it in this file and
what's special about this file is that
when the shell loads up it will run this
file and it will run these aliases first
before i even have a chance to do
anything else
in other words it will know about all
these aliases i define
so um let's see what should we do in
here i'll make it an alias called
um count
okay and count is going to echo
and if you remember our expansion i'll
just echo 1 to 99
i don't know why we do this but sure we
will
uh and then i'm going to save this file
so this is nano the easiest way is just
control s
and then i'm going to exit with control
x
okay
so can i run counts no i can't run count
just yet
i could open up a new window and it will
run that bash rc file and now if i try
running count hey it works
alternatively if i don't want to do that
i can actually source the command is
called source
my bashrc file and now i can run count
in this same window now if you're on a
mac
the default shell is z shell as we
discussed earlier
you could switch over to bash if you
wanted to
and just type bash and now i'm using
bash and i can define my files
or rather i can define my aliases
inside of my let's do ls-a here
lots of hidden files
inside of my bash profile here
that's where i could do it on a mac or
more likely if you're using z shell
which is the default shell
the file we want to add our alias to is
dot zshrc
where are you z
shrc right there
so that is our configuration file for z
shell so i can do nano dot z s h
r c
and scroll down i don't have to scroll
down i can define my aliases anywhere in
here but somewhere in here i can define
an alias so let's do a different i don't
know a different version of count
these are how we write comments by the
way
so if you want to have a little note or
you want to uh have something not take
effect you can put a octathorp or a hash
sign in front of it so alias let's call
this one um hmm
let's do
uh i'll just do another
i don't know count
count again but this time on my mac
count is going to be an echo
about
1 to 365
sure
all right
and that's it we could also define you
know l a more useful and how about ll
which will be ls dash l
and how about uh
we'll do l a
will be ls
dash l a
so
now
and actually why don't i do one more why
don't i alias rm
to instead be rm dash
verbose so it tells me when it deletes
something so i have that over on my
ubuntu
over here which you may have noticed so
let's just define those three alias or
four we have count lla and rm i
redefined the rm command to actually be
rm-v so that dash verbose option is
always there
i'll save and exit
yes i'll save okay so in a new window i
can run my count command
i have the ll command i have la which
also does hidden files we can see my
hidden files are showing up
and then i did the rm command so let's
just create a file called remove me
and delete me
now if i run rm on remove me and delete
me
oh well i
i didn't fully expand delete and to
delete me but still it shows me what it
removed so let's try try one more time
there let's rm delete
me
there we go and now it just tells me it
gives me a bit of feedback as to what
was deleted anyway that's the basics of
using the alias command remember where
you define those aliases first of all if
you don't define them in a file one of
these special files they will not
persist which is fine sometimes you may
not need them to but if you do define
them and you want them to continue to
exist every time you have a new terminal
window make sure you put them in the
appropriate file depending on whether
you're in zs you're using z shell or
bash or some other shell they all have
their own config files and one last note
about working with aliases and
specifically with quotes there's a
difference in uh bash between single
quotes and double quotes
when we have double quotes and we have a
variable or some form of
so remember there's this variable
expansion where we have a dollar sign
if i echo
some dollar sign and then a variable
like path
or there's user
the shell sees this and it expands that
or it replaces it with the actual value
for user cults and that is what is
echoed out okay so if i defined an alias
that i just wanted to i don't know how
about
well let's just use this example here
that is going to ls the contents of our
current directory if i do ls
dollar sign pwd
that's what both of these are
one has double quotes one has single
quotes the difference is that whenever
we use double quotes that variable is
going to be resolved the value will be
set in stone at the the definition time
when we actually run this originally
so whatever that pwd value is originally
it will always be that but if i use
single quotes instead
single quotes will be resolved or that
variable will be resolved whenever we
invoke this alias so this in other words
will be dependent on when i run this
it's not going to be the same thing
every time
versus this one here because i use
double quotes it's always going to be
whatever the value is i'll just show you
here
if i just paste this into my shell
currently the value of pwd it's my
current directory
so if i do ls this
it's printing the contents of my home
directory but if i go somewhere else
like my desktop and i rerun that
it's still printing the contents of my
home directory no matter where i am it
doesn't matter that i'm on the desktop
or if i go into uh
i don't know this wildlife folder and i
run ls this
because i used double quotes when i
defined that alias this was set in stone
at that moment i defined it
now if i instead did this so i'll copy
that and i'll put this in here alias ls
current
it is exactly the same inside the quotes
remember if i just echo pwd
it's a variable and it's just the exact
same thing i see if i type pwd but the
difference now is that this is going to
rerun every single time
that i run ls current
so if i go to my home directory and i
run ls current
it shows me the contents of my actual
current directory uh it doesn't matter
where i was when i defined this so
that's an important distinction when we
use double and single quotes next up we
get to talk about one of my favorite
commands it's not my favorite because i
use it very much that'd probably have to
be i don't know cd or ls or something
like that you just can't get around
using those all the time
but this command x args i don't use very
much at all but when i do use it it
really comes in handy it's pretty nifty
so here's the whole point of it
x-args exists to take
output from one command
and turn it into arguments for a second
command
so we've seen how we can take
something like well first i'll just show
you this folder i have i've got some
files
player two three four five six all the
way up to player nine or player ten
um so we've seen how we can do things
like take
ls and then pass that to sort for
example
right and what's happening here is that
the output of ls is being passed as the
input to the sort command
however when i say input i'm actually
referring to something called standard
input somewhat of a long explanation to
really go into but the idea is that
unlike other commands we've seen like
when we touch and make files i'll make
another file here player 11.txt
and
player12.txt
these are arguments being passed to the
touch command it's a list of values
separated by spaces
so when i run that we end up creating
what two new files and they're in here
but when we do ls
pipe sort we are not passing arguments
to sort and this is what's kind of
confusing the sort command is set up to
accept values
through standard input and it's also set
up to be able to sort things as
arguments so if i provided a file like i
have this file called dead players we'll
talk about that in a moment it can sort
the contents of that file as well so
this is passing an argument versus this
right here
we're passing the output of ls to the
standard input of sort
anyway i say all of this because only
certain commands are set up to work with
pipes
only certain commands like sort and
there's a lot of other ones that will
accept an input
through standard input rather than
through arguments but there are many
that don't so for example
touch is actually one i just showed you
i can't take the output of one command
and pass it to touch at least not
without x args so let me show what i'm
talking about i'm going to show you
first what we can't do the problem that
xrx solves
so i have some files here
player 1 through player 12 these
represent players in some game
and people die after each round of the
game and we need to
clear them out we need to get rid of the
players that died
so i have another file called dead
players if i just cat it out here you
can see it has the names or the files of
the players who are dead so what i want
to do is take this file whatever's in it
and delete or remove those files from
the actual folder
now this could be you know hundreds and
hundreds of dead players and we could
have thousands i actually recorded this
once where i did have thousands like
when i say once i mean like 10 minutes
ago i had thousands of players
and then i removed half of them but i
realized that the scale was too large
you really couldn't tell how many were
removed
so i scaled it down we're dealing with
12 now and we're going to delete what
five of them here
so aside from me manually doing rm
player one and so on the idea is that
this could scale up we could have
thousands of players and there's some
some list we don't even know you know
exactly what's in there but some list of
dead players it could be hundreds what i
want to do is take
whatever's in that file and dynamically
remove those files so whatever those
names are
what i can't do unfortunately is just
read the file so
we can cat it and then pipe it to rm
that will not work
because the rm command is one of those
commands that is expecting a space
separated list of arguments it is not
expecting anything to be passed to its
via standard input so that's what's
happening here with this pipe it takes
the output of cat and pipes it over to
rm but ram is not set up to handle that
so
just complains it says hey you didn't
pass anything in there's no argument so
what do you want me to rm just like if i
had run rm here
this is where x args comes in the x arcs
command will take or it will accept
standard input which is what's coming in
here from this pipe so cat the output is
passed to the standard n of rm but rm
doesn't want anything to do with it but
if we instead do
x args
if i can spell it rm
what it does is it's kind of like an
adapter it will take that standard in
and then turn it into
a list of arguments that will work for
rm
so this is the syntax
x args and then the command that you
want x-args to provide the arguments to
all right so we're going to take this
list of dead players
which when we cut that out it's
basically going to take this and provide
it to x-args x-args then says okay let
me turn that into a list of arguments
that will work for rm provide that to rm
and now
when i run it well
we see we lost a lot of players they're
now gone right i
this could scale up again to be hundreds
at one time
we can take the contents this is a
simple example take the contents of one
file and then do something with those
contents in this case we've removed
files that have that had those names
let's take a look at one more example uh
what i want to do is run the find
command
just uh on my desktop in all nested
folders and files uh to find how about
files that are larger so size is plus
one m so greater than one megabyte
and this is what it finds for me okay
but i want more information about these
i actually want to then uh do ls dash l
right so we get that long listing format
but i want ls-l only for these files
which is what seven or so files so um if
i try and pipe it to ls dash l
well surprise surprise ls is not set up
to accept values through standard input
which is what the pipe does
it is expecting
us to provide arguments sure after the
fact so we could do you know files that
end in txt
but that has nothing to do with our find
command i want to take the results of
the find command and then pass those to
ls-l in a format that it will accept
so this is again where x-args comes in
so this is the list of files that are
greater than one megabyte and then i can
do x-args oops
and then ls dash l that's the command i
want to run
and here we are we now see let's
actually do lh so i can get the human
readable format for the sizes
not very large files on here 1.8 1.8
megabytes 1.2 1.2 but these are all the
files that we found from that find
command
uh those values were then passed to xrx
xox stepped in and turned it into a
acceptable list of arguments that was
then provided to ls-lh
and that's how we see this output
so there's actually quite a bit more to
x-args i'm not going to go into here
you can read the man pages
it's pretty powerful the different ways
you can construct
the list of arguments the different
separators and delimiters and you can
have it replace different things for you
along the way
you can limit the number of arguments
it's quite complicated but what i just
showed you are some of the more common
simple ways of using it and that's the
core purpose of x-args is to take
standard input and turn it into a list
of arguments that other commands will
accept all right so next up we're going
to talk about the ln command which is
used to create links ln link now when i
say link it's not a hyperlink or you
know something from a browser
a link in linux is or it may be a new
concept to you
it's kind of similar to the idea of a
shortcut your desktop shortcuts on a
windows operating system
where you have some applications that
are installed somewhere else it is not
on your desktop they are installed
completely in a different area but you
have access to start them up you can
reference them through the icons on your
desktop so there's a link
those icons have a little picture of
whatever adobe photoshop that icon on my
desktop when i double click it
it is linked it's referencing some
actual program that it starts up
so the concept is similar we can have a
file that is linked that points to
another file
so there are two types of links
hard links and soft links we'll start by
covering hard links which actually are
not used as frequently
but the idea is when we create a hard
link we are creating basically a file
that will stay in sync with another file
now we're not creating a copy we're not
duplicating a file it's different they
are pointing to the same thing the same
exact file so they're not diverging
they're not copies it's not like using
the cp command that's important to
understand so let me show you an example
we'll start nice and simple i've got an
empty folder
i'm going to echo
i am original into a file called
original.txt
all right so i just made this new file
we can cat it out and it says i am
original and that's the only file in
here
now the syntax to make a hard link is ln
and then the original file which happens
to be called original and then whatever
our destination or not destination but
whatever the name of the link file that
we want to create is i'm going to call
mine hardlink.txt
so if i type ls we have two files now or
what appears to be two files uh this
hard link file
if i cat it out
says i am original it has the same
contents remember though it is not a
copy it is pointing to the same file as
this right here
so if i change original let's echo
this is more
stuff
we'll append that into original
so if we cat out original we see two
lines now and if i cat out the hard link
we also see two lines
and this goes both directions because
they're both referring to the exact same
thing if i change hard link
uh change from hard link
and i echo that into the
hard link file
which is a hard link to that original
file
this is what it looks like now
and if i cat the original
it also has that change so they are two
things two arrows pointing to that same
file in memory and this means if i were
to delete
well first if i delete the hard link the
original file is still there it's
unchanged but if i delete the original
file
my hard link file will persist it is
pointing to that same thing in memory
and that's what's a little bit confusing
here
it is not pointing to the you know this
name original.txt it's pointing it's
called an inode it doesn't really matter
but it's referring to
the same thing in memory just two
different names for it so if i remove
original
i'll remove it
it's gone but our hard link file that is
still there that hard link we created
and it still has
those contents inside so that's a hard
link as i mentioned it's not as commonly
used
then we have soft links
and soft links are different the first
thing you should know
is that to make one we use the dash s
option if you just take a look at man ln
and then scroll down
somewhere on here here we are dash s for
symbolic it will make a symbolic link
soft link instead of a hard link so
what i'm going to do here is remove my
hard link
and i'm going to create a new original
file so we'll echo i am original again
into
original.txt
oh i did dot tt but that's fine
um just quick quiz how would i rename
that
without moving it anywhere
easiest way is just move command
original dot txt is the destination and
there we go
okay so i'm going to make a soft link
and to do that it's ln
s
the file that i'm linking to and then
the new soft link or the sim link
symbolic link
i'm going to just call simlink.txt
okay
so
what i have now is a symbolic link or a
soft link and if i type ls
you'll see if you have colors enabled it
really depends on the terminal you're
using your operating system your shell
but for most
terminals it will probably be a
difference and for me it's bolded
and it is in a different color cyan
it doesn't matter what color it is and
even if there's no color difference it
doesn't matter if we do ls-l
we can see a difference as well if you
notice here here's my original file
here's the sim link file it has this
little arrow pointing to that original
file
additionally over here we haven't really
talked about permissions yet
but there's a difference there's a dash
here is the first digit and there's an l
here as the first digit
this tells us that it is a symbolic link
it's a link
anyway
just like before
if i change the original file
let's do a echo
change to original
and then we will append that to the
original file
it now looks like this
and if i echo or rather cat the simlink
file
it also prints out the exact same thing
now what if i try and change this sim
link file echo change to sim link
and i append that to the sim link file
all right let's see did that change the
sim link
and does that mean the original has
changed
yeah it goes both ways in this sense
however where there's a big difference
is if i delete the original file
so i have both of them here right now if
i remove original
yes
now we have this simlink.txt
but it doesn't look very happy it's
still there
but it's showing up in red all of a
sudden and if i try and cat the contents
it says no such file or directory so
it's this link that it's just pointing
to something that doesn't even exist
anymore
so that's the main difference the
symbolic link was pointing to
original.txt and when original is gone
that link is severed with a hard link
a hard blank is pointing to don't think
of it as pointing to the file itself but
think of the hard link and original.txt
as two different pointers to the same
thing in memory
so if i delete the original it's all
right we still have the hard link it's
pointing to that same thing in memory
but here with a sim link i delete the
original
well now this sim link has nothing to
link to and it still is there right we
still see something show up but it's
just completely dead inside now you
might be wondering why would you ever do
this why does it matter
and this is one of the harder things to
explain or to convince you of when
you're a beginner and i honestly don't
even use sim links all that much or any
links
although i end up working with people
who do use them and so i you know need
to be familiar and comfortable working
with them it's pretty straightforward
once you get used to just that dash s
ln-s but let me show you an example um
if you have python installed for me i
have python i think it came
pre-installed and ubuntu and i have a
couple different versions i'm going to
run an ls-l
on this directory user bin
and then
python i'll come back to in a moment but
user bin is where binaries are installed
uh and so it's where python binaries
will live by default uh and there's a
lot in here so first of all if i just
get rid of this python thing
there's a lot of different programs in
here
uh one of which i'm just going to focus
on for now is python
so if i do an ls dash l user slash bin
and then anything that starts with
python maybe i'll even do python 3
because i have python 2 and 3. what we
see here let me clear everything else
again and just focus on this
what you'll see is that there's four
matches
there's
user bin python 3.8
3-futurized
3-pasteurize
and then
there's this right here what is that
that is a sim link
and that sim link is just called python
3 but it's pointing to a specific
version
so when i run python3
that's the command i'm running when i
run that right here it's actually a sim
link and it's referring right now to 3.8
but this allows me to manage different
versions i could then have 3.9 or
three-point you know python versions
that don't exist yet or older versions
3.5
i can have them all installed and then
whatever this sim link it's like a
shortcut whatever python 3 is referring
to is what version of python will run
so i can manage i can have all those
versions installed but only one that is
actually run when i call python3 so one
with this little shortcut
and i run python3 and there we go it
doesn't matter if you know python or not
uh and it actually we have the same
thing if i just do python star
python 2
i only have one version installed but i
have a sim link and i don't set this up
myself to be clear this was just done
for me when i installed python
but python2 simlink is referring to
there's a little arrow
python 2.7 but i could also have 2.8 and
2.5
and then switch versions and when i
switch versions python 2 will point to
one of those versions
so that's just a simple example but
there are many ways you can use sim
links for now though i just want you to
understand that ln is a command and that
there are two different types of links
we can make we can make a hard link and
a soft link also known as a sim or
symbolic link all right the next couple
of commands we'll learn have to do with
users and permissions uh they're pretty
important ones that may not come up all
the time but when they do come up they
are really really useful um so on linux
we can have multiple users logged in at
the same time um doesn't really happen
for me i'm kind of just working on my
own on this one machine and for most
people
i shouldn't say most but i imagine for a
lot of you who are watching this video
you may be the only person using your
machine but it's important to understand
that you can have multiple users all
logged in simultaneously to your same
machine it might be hard to do right you
may not have the the
multiple screens and keyboards and
whatever needed to have different people
logged in at the same time although it
can also be accomplished virtually the
point is it's possible
there is a command called who
not to be confused with who am i who am
i tells us the
username based on the current effective
user id for me that's cold steel here on
my mac
who is going to tell us about the users
who are logged in and like i said for me
it's really just me
uh but what we'll actually see if i type
it on my mac
is
currently what five seven different uh
well if you include this one eight but
right here what we're seeing are seven
different uh users it's the same user
but they're
each added here separately for each time
i access or each time i log in via a
terminal basically every terminal window
counts as a user accessing
so i have seven right now
this is tty is it it's teletype i
believe it's an old relic but
anyway if i create a new terminal window
just
ignore it uh and then run who again we
now see we've got a 4 which wasn't there
before you may not see that but if i
zoom way in
it says last login on ttyso
so um yep
that's why we're seeing all of those
there anyway not the most useful command
certainly not right now
and not for me because i'm the only user
but if we're an administrator and we've
got a whole bunch of people on a machine
at once
this could be pretty critical to know
who is currently logged in
next up we'll cover the su command which
is short for switch user this command
allows us to switch users to log in as
someone else within a terminal show
so you may have situations where you
might need to do this
maybe not it really depends on
what you're working on and how your
machine is set up
but if you are an administrator for
example and you need to do something on
somebody else's account
well all you need to do is run the su
command followed by some username
now i have a different user on this
machine so remember i'm colt on this
ubuntu uh distribution here right now
that's who i'm logged in as but i have
a user called elvis
and when i do su elvis it asks me to
enter elvis's password so i can't just
switch users to be whoever i want
without knowing passwords unless i'm a
root user unless i have full permissions
but i don't
so
i switch user to elvis i need to know
elvis password and i
think nope i'm pretty sure i just got it
wrong
i did this last night let's see
there we go entered the correct password
uh and you'll see my prompt changes now
says elvis at my ubuntu and if i type
who am i it now says your elvis
but just to be very clear this is in one
window
over here
i'm still cult so i haven't completely
logged out and become elvis everywhere
it's still
my horribly messy desktop but i am elvis
in this tab
aside from what we see when i run who am
i if i cd to my home directory
well my home directory tilde if i do pwd
is home slash elvis
whereas over here i cd2 tilde and i do
pwd
home slash colt is my home directory
so as elvis i can do things like
well there's nothing in this home
directory but i could make a file
touch from
elvis.txt
and i have permission to do that
but if i go
back and i go into
colts account or rather colt's home
folder
remember i'm logged in as elvis here not
colt
uh what happens if i try and make a file
here called from
elvis.txt
i can't do that
so i'm logged in as elvis but that
doesn't mean i can do everything colt
can do we have different permissions and
that's something we're going to start to
try and understand we'll walk through
how permissions work
but this is just a quick introduction to
the concept that different users have
different permissions they can do
different things
and if i went the other direction as
colt
you know i can make a folder or a file
from colts here no problem
but if i back out and i try and go into
elvis's directory i can do that but if i
try and make a file touch from colts.txt
no luck i can't do that i don't have
permission
anyway uh that's the basic idea of using
su you probably wouldn't do this just
make a random folder or file in somebody
else's home directory but if you do need
to switch users that's how you do it you
need to enter the password and then to
get out of here i think you can type
exit also you can just do control d or
control c i believe
now there's another option when we run
su if i do man su
there's this dash that we can provide
and if you provide that dash let's see
if i can find it here
it will start the shell as a login shell
with an environment similar to a real
login this means it clears all the
environment variables it initializes the
environment variable's home shell user
log name and path and it changes us over
to the target user's home directory so
remember when i logged in as elvis i was
actually just in colt's home directory
anyway it didn't take me to elvis's
directory like a normal login would
but if i instead do s u
dash
and then elvis i can also do dash l
but it's so common that you can just do
dash it's a very short option i'll type
elvis password
and it takes me right to elvis's home
directory this acts as a real login
shell and then to get out of here
again i can type exits or it is control
d i believe there we go
okay so that is su to switch users next
up we'll talk about the sudo command
s-u-d-o
which is short for super user do
and the command allows us to
run commands other commands as the root
user or with elevated permissions
so there's this concept of the root user
a user in linux who
basically has permission to do anything
to
create new users to change passwords to
remove files and folders and we actually
if i just run ls dash l here i'm logged
in as colt
what we see here in this third column is
the owner of particular files and
folders
but if i keep backing out
now we see you know my different users
if i take a look at one of them like
kitty
kitty owns these files and folders in
her his or her desktop
or home folder rather but if i back out
another level
so here i am one more time
now we see a bunch of these really
important directories uh that i who owns
who who owns you know the bin folder
where i have things like
if we just cdn there
all our programs are installed
who's in charge of that which user well
if i type ls-l
we see root all over the place the root
user is in charge or not in charge the
root user is the owner of these programs
these files and folders uh and that's
just one example of you know the
significance of root root can do all
sorts of things
like i said a root user can change
someone else's password but as colt's
just a regular old user i can't do that
now there's something very important to
know on ubuntu at least in many linux
distributions the root user account is
actually locked it's not accessible you
can't log into it there's no password
i can't just log out and log back in as
root if i go to log out
we will see
yes i'll log out
we saw the text root all over the place
in my terminal
but there is no root account that i can
actually log in as
so why is this well it's just how ubuntu
is set up
it was a decision that was made
rather than having a single root account
with a single password that you can log
in as instead
individual users i have four here colt
kitty carrot and elvis individual users
uh may be able to run commands as the
root user and that's where this pseudo
command comes in
so how does this work
it's not like it's a free-for-all and
every single user on a machine can run
commands as the root user
uh those permissions are are actually
listed out in a particular file
there's a lot that goes into it and
managing those permissions but i'm just
going to show you though
is that when you create your initial
user account so colt was my initial user
account whoops
i'm logged in now as colts and i'm
looking at my settings i can see
different users again none of them are
called roots but some of them including
colt which was the first account i made
by default is an administrator so that
means i can add and remove other users i
can change settings for all users
but that's not the same as being the
root user
and then some other users carrot elvis
are not administrators kitty is an
administrator when you make a new user
you can decide that now that's just one
basic
difference or one basic
toggle between permissions but we can
get very detailed about who is allowed
to do what but we're not going to go
into that i just wanted to make it clear
that this sudo command i'm about to show
you is not carte blanche for every user
to do everything so i'll demonstrate
that
okay so how do we use this sudo command
the idea is that instead of using a
single root password each user has their
own password we enter that password it's
going to prompt us for that password and
then it's going to check do you even
have permission to run this command as
root so it doesn't turn us into the root
user
it doesn't give us permissions to do
everything if we don't already have them
it only allows us to do certain commands
that we are specifically already
permitted to do it's just an extra level
of protection basically you have to type
sudo you have to type your password so
even if you have those permissions you
can't just normally go around deleting
everyone's stuff
you need to run sudo in order to do that
so if i wanted to
edit some particular configuration file
that affects everyone on a machine
if i just tried to open it in nano i'm
not going to be able to do that but if i
try using sudo first i'll enter my
password and it will check if i'm
allowed to do that or not so let me show
you uh let me get my terminal open
so the file that we're going to look at
is in slash etsy etc
host that's the name of the file
and if i just do an ls-l on it
remember this is a high up directory it
is not located in colt's user directory
or any other user it's above
and if i run ls-l we can see that the
owner is the root user but again there
is actually no way to log in as the root
user in ubuntu
so
uh if i want to edit this file for some
reason i could try running nano
and it does open up i can actually read
the contents but it tells me for you
this file is unwritable
so i can't make changes
i'll get out of here but if i now prefix
this with sudo
super user do
this so super user do this command it's
first going to say enter your password
for colts that's who i currently am and
it's going to check if i have permission
if i am granted those root permissions
to edit this particular file
so if i enter my password this is not
the root password this is colt's
password that i log in with
and we see i actually am able to edit
this file i'm not going to
because i really don't want to but this
is a file i can change now
but if i go
log in as a different user and remember
we saw how to do this
i can use su dash i have elvis as a user
on this account
i'll type elvis's password
okay
who am i i am elvis so if i try and run
this nano etc
hosts i also see hey you don't have
permission to do that that's a file
owned by root
but if i try sudo
just like i did as colt it now asks me
for elvis's password so what is elvis's
password well i'm not telling you
but i know it i type it in
and it tells me
nope that's not going to work we checked
elvis is not in the sudoers or sudoers
file we're not going to really go into
that but there's ways of managing who
can do what it's more of an
administrative process or a specialty
that i'm just not going to go into here
but it's important to note specific
users can have different permissions who
is allowed to do what as the root user
and elvis doesn't have any
so i can't edit that file as elvis but
again if i switch back to being cult
i'll just get out of here with exit
and i run that sudo nano blah blah blah
i already entered my password so it
remembers it there just to be clear
but you will need to enter your password
when you run sudo your particular user's
password now you've probably actually
come across this before when it comes to
installing software or installing new
commands there's a command
called tldr i don't have it installed
and if i try typing it
my shell is going to tell me i don't
know what you're talking about but here
are some things you could try installing
so there's a command called apt install
and then the package tldr
but if i just run that without sudo
i'm not allowed to do that
because i'm installing something that
is not even just specific to my user
here it actually is specific or not
specific it would apply to all users on
my machine i'm actually installing a
program a command that everyone can use
so i can't just go around doing that i
need to have permission so that's why we
run sudo
do i have permission to install this
well i already entered my password again
so it knows who i am and what
permissions i have
to do as root user i can install it so i
will continue
and it will take a little while to
install
the the point of this is not to show you
how to install things by the way it's
just to show you another situation where
you would need to use sudo
so anytime you're trying to make changes
you run into a permission denied error
you'll often be prompted to try it again
with sudo first
so sudo itself we prefix in front of
other commands
and then it will prompt us for our
password and now i have this tl dr
command just show it to you on the man
page for it here we are anyway uh it
really doesn't matter it was just about
using sudo so it really depends on who
you're logged in as and what permissions
you specifically have been granted and
that is something that can be tweaked it
can be really
down to a pretty granular level i
haven't changed anything it's just that
some users have administrator
permissions on here some of them don't
now not all linux distributions will
have the root account locked so you
can't log into it directly some of them
you can but even then we still have
access to the sudo command and we can
grant specific users
different privileges as root it's also
you know on my mac i cannot run things
with sudo and i often need to if i'm
installing something that is system-wide
same idea the next command will cover is
the password command which is actually
pass wd
i guess those extra two letters are too
long
and this is the command we can use to
change someone's password so there's two
ways of using it you can change your own
password by just typing passwd
so i'm logged in as called i don't
really i mean i guess i'll change my
password then i'll change it back
so it's going to ask me for my current
password so i have to know that and then
it asked me for my new password
and let's do uh
well i'm not gonna tell you and then i
have to confirm it again
okay i updated my password and you can
just trust that it worked i mean
i how would you really know i guess i'm
not going to tell you what it was before
or now although none of them are
actually real passwords anyway but it
did change and if i were to log out i
would need to use that new password so
i'm just going to change it back one
more time current password whoops i
messed up i'm gonna do that again so my
current password i just changed it to
my new one
okay now i can also change someone
else's password uh assuming i have root
permissions uh so let's say i need to
change elvis password he's forgotten it
there's actually a lot you can do you
can lock someone's password
you can
if we just go to man
pass wd
you can do things like
expire an account's password which would
force them to change their password next
time they log in but it doesn't actually
give them a new password you can make an
empty password to disable a password for
an account there's a lot here um i'm
just going to show the basics so i want
to change elvis password
pass wd
elvis
well
i can't do that right as colts i need to
do it as the root user or i guess as
elvis uh but as the root user is
probably more likely right why would
elvis need to change his password from
my account uh so if i have permissions
i'm the administrator remember on ubuntu
i can't log in as root so this is the
closest thing i'm an admin i have
permission to do this but i have to use
sudo
so sudo password elvis is now going to
ask me for my password not elvises it's
going to ask me for mine and it's going
to just verify are you even allowed to
do that as colt
okay
now it's asking me for elvis's new
password
so i'm just going to change it to
how about hacked
okay and one more time
and now i just changed elvis password
i guess you know i could show it to you
quickly if i do an su elvis
if i try and use elvis's old password
which was
something involving the word taco it
doesn't work but now if i log in as
elvis using hacked
it does work
and then as elvis i could change my
password again
using password
and i don't need any fancy permissions
you can change your own password
all right so that's the basic use of
password it is past wd there is more to
it as i said you can lock someone's
password you can delete it uh you can
expire it and force them to set a new
one when they log in
but again it comes down to you can
change your own password or if you have
permission as the root user
you can use sudo in order to change
somebody else's password the next
command we'll cover is one of my
favorites to say out loud chon or town
change ownership
this is the command we can use to change
who owns a particular file or directory
so let's talk about what that means to
own a file or directory um on every file
every directory let me just go home here
i'm logged in as colt
who am i
um when we do ls-l
we see a whole bunch of information
we're going to talk more about what this
is in just a little bit permissions
and then this right here this third
column
is the owner of the entry so in this
case the owner of this directory files
exercise is me cold
uh the owner of music is colt
this is pretty normal to own all the
stuff in your home directory
but if i go to somebody else's directory
if i have multiple users let's go to
kitty's directory so this is her home
directory
kitty owns almost all of these files and
folders and if i keep backing out
further we've seen this before
root
the root user owns all of these
directories and files
so the chon command helps us change who
owns those files and that's important to
do because the owner of a file is
allowed to
change its permissions to delete it
potentially to read or to write to that
file
it all has to do with what we see over
here which we'll get into in just a
little bit but for now i just want to
show that we can change the owner
and then we'll understand we'll try to
understand its implications later on
when we talk about another command all
right so i'm going to go back home
and
the syntax to change the owner looks
like this tone
and then the owner that we want to
add as the owner so a user
and then the file that we're trying to
change
so um i'm going to go into elvis's
directory
or maybe
it doesn't really matter here i'll go
into kitties
kitty
all these files almost all of them
are owned by kitty
if i wanted to if i wanted to change the
owner of how about kitty's music
directory
the syntax would be change owner chone
and then me colt that's the user i'm
trying to add as the owner and then
after that
music
now there is a bit of a problem
i can't just change somebody else's you
know i can't just make myself the owner
of somebody else's directory uh all over
the place like that is something i have
to have permission to do
and we've recently learned that we can
use the pseudo command to act as the
root user
so that is one option here is if i have
root permissions i can change the owner
of any files sudo
tone cult music
so it's going to ask me for my password
and then i enter it and i don't see
anything but that's a good sign
that means that i did have permission to
do that
and now you can see cult is indeed the
owner of this music directory
now again we haven't really talked about
what that means for me to be the owner
but i'll just show you for example if i
were to go into the desktop
and try and create a file touch made by
colt
i don't have permission in that
directory but if i go back out and i go
into music
if i touch a file touch made by colt
i do have permission now because i am
the owner
as we saw i did ls-l
i own that folder music one commonly
used flag with chone is uppercase r
which we can use to recursively change
the ownership of all the files and
subdirectories nested in a directory
so i have this directory i just made
called cat stuff
and it has
some files inside of it and then a
nested directory with some other files
and if i decide i want to make the owner
of cat stuff kitty and this is all kind
of silly and you probably won't just
make a directory in your home folder and
then make someone else the owner at
least not frequently but just for demo
purposes if i make kitty another user on
my
computer if i make her the owner
i can do chone
kitty
and then i need the name of that
directory which is cat stuff and i do
need to use sudo
even though it's my own folder that
might seem weird like you should be able
to change who owns your own stuff
the way linux is set up that is not the
case you still need to have root
permissions
now you can change the permissions
attributes we'll talk about very very
shortly uh if you are the owner um but
you can't change the actual owner of a
file unless you have root permissions
and i already typed my password a couple
minutes ago or seconds ago so i don't
have to redo it
and if i do ls-l we see
where are you
cat stuff kitty is the owner but if we
cdn to cat stuff
ls-l
i cult still own all the files and the
nested directory so to change that we
can just rerun that line
the tone line
but we use the dash uppercase r to
recursively change the ownership and now
if i go back into cat stuff
kitty is indeed the owner of all the
nested contents if we go into toys same
thing there kitty is the owner of those
files
okay
now another thing you may notice when i
run ls-l
let me go to uh how about kitty's home
folder
so we'll go
slash home slash kitty
instead of here when i do ls-l on any it
doesn't matter where but in this
directory ls lsl i see a bunch of
folders and files there's an owner that
we talked about
that is a single user who is the owner
of that file
but then
why does it say kitty again or here it
says pals forever what is this second
thing
this is known as the group owner this is
a little confusing but every file on a
linux system has an owner and it has a
group that owns it and that group can
have multiple people's people users who
are members of that group and then the
group can get its own set of permissions
so this means that um you know i could
be the owner of this file and i might be
able to read write delete whatever i
want and then
members of the pals forever group might
be able to read only but they're not
able to edit this file they're not able
to write to it
so this allows us to have two different
levels of permissions the owner can have
some set of permissions what are they
allowed to do and then members of the
group that is an owner the group owner
they also can have a separate set of
permissions
and it's all encoded in these weird
little digits that rwx and dash is here
we will talk about that very soon but
what i want to show you right now is
that we can just change the group that
owns a file using chone now this is
something you probably won't do very
much and i'm not diving into groups and
managing groups and creating new groups
and changing members who belongs to a
group that's all more admin stuff anyway
not day-to-day user stuff at least in my
experience and with my students
but it's worth knowing that we can use
the shown command to change the group
owner
so i have this group called pals forever
i can actually there's a command called
groups i can see all the groups that i
the current user belongs to so here's
all the groups we've got
uh movie club
pals forever let's say i want to change
the group that owns music
from kitty and this is also somewhat
confusing by default the group
is going to be a group with your
username
so it says kitty and kitty but this is
the group owner this is the owner owner
all right
if i want to take this music directory
and make
pals forever the group owner the syntax
looks like this
where we have the owner name a colon and
then the group that we want to add
so here if i want to keep the owner as
colt i need to do pseudo chone
cult colon pals forever
and then
music is what i'm trying to change
so this will be the owner and this is
the group owner
ls-l and if we look at music that group
has changed
now again the idea behind groups is that
we could have 10 different users who are
part of this group and they might be
able to read this directory only
but then the owner
can read and write and execute and do
everything
so we can have these different levels so
it's not just one person who's allowed
to do things for the file we can
selectively change these groups
and add people to the groups but that
again is a more advanced admin thing we
don't really need to worry about
all right so the next thing we're going
to talk about
is understanding when i do ls-l the very
first chunk of really bizarre looking
text these characters here we want to
understand what these are what they mean
because we're also going to learn a
command that allows us to change these
so what we're looking at right here
is for every file every directory
these are the permissions or the file
attributes they
detail what the owner is allowed to do
can you read write or execute this file
uh what the group members who are part
of the group that owns this file can do
read write and execute and what everyone
else can do can
the world at large any user read write
or execute
so there's a lot to break down there's
actually 10 digits here not digits 10
characters
and the first character
actually i'm using some of my slides
i've made for a course on udemy if
you're interested in a lot more of a
deep dive into linux commands
because this is just hard to explain
without graphics or some visuals so
anyway that first letter is either going
to be a dash so not a letter that
indicates that it's a file a plain old
regular file id
indicates a directory so we can see that
already here's a file dot txt it has a
dash
that's the first character here's a
folder or a directory it has a d
and then for sim links i think if i just
back out a little bit here
they'll start with an l so here's a sim
link here we can see we also have that
arrow pointing to you know where the
link is linking to
and it starts with an l so that's the
first thing
that's kind of just a one-off then we
have nine characters which is actually
three sets of three
the first group of three tells us the
permissions for the owner of the file or
directory
the second group tells us the
permissions for the group owner or for
members in that group
and then finally the third group
tells us the permissions for everyone
else the world at large any other user
that's not the owner or that is not part
of the group that owns the file or
folder now within each group of three
we'll just take the first one so for an
owner those first three digits
they tell us the read writes and execute
permissions for this file can the owner
read write or execute so those three
characters in a very particular order
the read permission is first then the
right permission then the execute and
then it starts over
read write execute for the group owner
or group members read write and execute
for everyone else
so what do these three permissions mean
well
if we have an r in that first spot right
here there's an r here there's an r here
there's an arm
that means that the file can be read if
it's a file or if it's a directory it
means that the contents of that
directory can be listed okay so here i
have a single file i've created called
onlycoltscanread.txt
and we'll learn how you can change these
permissions but i've already changed
them the first thing we see here is a
dash that means that it's a file
then we have those first three digits
which are the owner permissions now the
owner is colt
and there is an r present here which
means that i have permission to read
the owner whoever that is has permission
to read the contents of this file and i
can read it
okay
then we have the next three
which is all just dashes which means
none of those permissions are present so
this is the group permissions anyone
who's a member of this group well they
don't have any permissions here and then
everyone else
they also don't have permissions so that
r would be that character right there
there is no r that means whenever we
have a dash that the file is not
readable
or executable or writable depending on
the location of where that dash is
so here if there's a dash that means the
owner couldn't read it but there is not
a dash there's a r which means we do
have read permissions so let me
demonstrate this if i switch over i'm
just going to log in as elvis
if i can remember the password
uh oh that's not it
all right let's try that again
oh wait i think i changed it to hacked
didn't i i forgot about that
there we go all right so i'm now elvis
who am i
if i do an ls-l well i'm not cult i'm
not part of this group uh so i'm
considered anyone else i don't have read
permissions there's just a dash there if
i try and cat the file out
permission denied only colt can read
that file or only the owner which
happens to be colt
okay
so this pattern holds true for all of
these permissions if there's a dash in
any of these spots it means that that
respective if it's the world the group
the owner does not have that permission
so here we can see the owner does not
have execute permissions the group does
not have execute permissions everyone
else does not have write or execute
permissions
now what those mean we'll dive into but
for reading as we saw
if there's an r there that means the
file can be read
and if there's an r on a directory that
means that we can list the contents of
that directory
so this is why
as elvis
i can do ls or ls-l or something on this
directory
it's actually going to zoom out further
or move back one level
if we look here
this is each user's home folder so we've
got carrot colts elvis and kitty
each user has rwx that means read write
and execute
but then
there's an r present for everyone else
for that world right everyone can still
read these directories
that doesn't mean i can change them of
course but this is why as elvis i can go
into colts directories and and list ls-l
i have that permission because i have
that r attribute right there
in that third set so remember
first three
that's going to be the owner
members of the group
and then everyone else
and i currently
and part of that everyone else i'm able
to read the contents here but uh through
some editing magic uh i did just change
the permissions on the permissions
directory here if you notice now there
is no r present we'll learn how to
change that in a bit uh on this third
grouping which means that anyone who is
not the owner or part of this group
cannot read the contents of this
directory now it is a directory so what
does that mean remember the r character
means that you can list the contents of
a directory if it's a directory or you
can read the contents of a file if it's
a file
well i'm elvis still if i try an ls that
permissions folder
i can't
i can ls any of the others i can ls
music i can ls desktop but when i try
permissions
i can't do that because once again
we no longer have an r present there
but if i switch back to being cold
now i'm cold
we can see
i can
ls permissions no problem
because we have an r in that first
grouping which is the owner's permission
so i can read all right so that's our
first
type of permission read permission
if there's an r present here here or
here that means that either the owner
members of the group or everyone else
can read
next we have this second slot which is
for write permissions so a dash means no
write permissions a w means write
permissions
so for a file that means that we can
modify the file and for a directory this
means that the contents can be modified
you could change files you could make a
new file for example you could rename
but
this actually only takes effect if the
executable attribute is also set which
is that third piece here so let's just
focus on files so if we have a w present
that means we can write to a file so
here we have ilovekitty.txt
the owner is cult
there's a w there right here's that
first group or i shouldn't say group but
the first chunk
123 for the owner i can write to that
file uh i can echo into it let's just do
echo meow
into i love
no i need uppercase l
no problem i'm cold i can do that if i
cat it out
we see it has meow
but now if i switch back to being elvis
put elvis's new hacked password in there
i am elvis here
if i as elvis try and add to that file
if i try and open it with nano if i try
and echo something into it
well elvis is not cult so these
permissions don't apply not part of that
group parallels so these don't apply but
it doesn't matter anyway because it's
the same as the permissions for everyone
else
what we see here is that
everyone has read permissions
but no write permissions
so i cannot write to that file
if i try to echo
um i don't know hi from elvis into i
love kitty
permission denied i cannot write to that
file
but i can print it out or read the
contents because once again we have
that r right there so i'm elvis that r
applies to me i'm not the owner i'm not
part of this group we have read but no
write permissions and then what about
this third slot here
so that third slot is either going to be
an x or a dash if it's a dash it means
no execute or executable permissions
if it's an x that means we do have
executable permissions so what does that
mean
well it's easier to understand in the
context of directories if we have a
directory
you'll see actually there's a lot of x's
on directories by default everyone has x
executable permissions on folders all
that means is that we can cd into a
directory
so
it doesn't matter who i am right now
let's take a look at the wildlife
directory
there's an x present for the owner group
members and for everyone else so i'm
currently elvis i can cd into wildlife
no problem
i'm in there
now if i behind the scenes get rid of
that x i'll do it right now there we go
there is no x there anymore we're about
to see how to do that
i'm going to go back to being elvis
if i try and cd into wildlife now
cd into wildlife
permission denied
we don't have an x there
and for elvis that means he can't
execute you cannot cd into that
directory now members of the group
parallels in this case anyone who's in
that group can and then the owner cult
can cd as well because that's the owners
execute the group members execute and
then everyone else is execute
so normally you'll have x present all
over the place for directories but i
just removed it here to show you the
consequences i'll go back to being cult
and i can cd into wildlife no problem
now it's a little trickier to explain
what it means when we have a file
for files that have an x present here
so if i were to show you a couple of
examples like this right here these
permissions
means that an owner has read write and
execute permissions for this file no one
else has any access whatsoever
what does that x mean on a file
it means that the file can be treated as
a program and can be executed
so if you write your own scripts you
write your own programs and you want
them to become
executable you need to have that x there
so we're not going to see that right now
but i'll show you some examples of
things that are executables if we cd
back a couple of times
we go into bin
what we see here if i do an ls-l
are lots of x is present but these are
actually files so these are programs
as you can see
so there's a lot of programs here uh
once again i'm in slash
slash bin rather is my path name right
now
binaries this is where programs are
stored
so uh if you know here's touch for
example that is a program that i can run
obviously we use it all the time or if
we find let's see is there another
simple one in here here we go here is
echo
so our echo program that we run that
command it's defined right here it's a
file it has some code in there
and as you see it's x x x that means we
can execute it as a program we can
actually run it okay so what i want to
demonstrate is a little odd but there's
a program called ncal it gives us a
calendar
uh i'm going to make it so i can't
actually execute that and then i'm going
to undo it but i'm not going to show you
how just yet i'm just going to
demonstrate so if i do an ls-l on ncal
in slash bin here it is
we see the owner which is root members
of the group which is also root and
everyone else has that x present that
means anyone can execute this
i'm going to change that so i just did
that
now i do ls
dash l on ncal again this program
no longer has an x right there it did
just a moment ago
now this means that only the owner which
is root i'm not root only members of the
group root which i'm not a member of
can execute everyone else does not have
that x there no executable permissions
on this file
so now if i try and run ncal
oh
permission denied i can't run that
script i cannot use that command anymore
because it's not executable
so that x is very very important uh and
you probably wouldn't go around removing
those
but just to show you what the
significance is so to reiterate if
there's an x present for a directory
that means you can cd into it but for a
file that means you can execute it so
i'm going to undo that we're going to
learn this command that i used to do it
it's called chamod change mode
but now if i run that ls-lncal
i have that x back and now i can run
ncal again
okay
so now we're going to learn how to use
this command to change those permissions
i just want to run through one more time
what these three things mean well
there's ten things i guess the first is
a dash for a file a d for a directory an
l for sim link and then we have three
groups of three
each of these groupings has three places
the first is either an r or a dash and r
means read permission is present dash
means no read permission
w write permission a dash means no right
permission and then the final slot is
for execute x means it's executable
no x a dash means you don't have that
permission so the first three read write
execute are for the owner of the file or
folder the second three are for members
of the group that owns that file or
folder and then the final three are for
everyone else so what does this mean a
little quiz here uh what do these this
exact set of attributes mean first of
all are we talking about directory file
sim link
answer for your moment or think about it
for a moment answer out loud if you'd
like we are looking at a file
and we can see the owner whoever that is
has full permissions read write and
execute members of the group owner have
read writes but no execute permissions
and everyone else only has read
permissions
okay
so now let's talk about how we actually
change these how do we use this weird
chamod to mode however you want to
pronounce it command
it first of all stands for change mode
and it is the tool it's the command we
use to alter those permissions and
here's the basic syntax there's actually
two main ways of using chamod of
specifying the permissions
and the first i'm going to show you is
the easier one when you're starting out
so we have the command
chamod change mode
and then the mode meaning how we want to
change the permissions who are we
changing permissions for what are we
changing
read write execute and are we adding or
removing that permission and then
finally the file that we're trying to
change
so
this is where it gets a little tricky
the first thing we specify is the who
we have these different letters u g o
and a
so u is how we can change the the file
permissions for the user which is the
owner of the group it's a little
confusing because o is actually for
others anyway if we have u
that means we're changing permission for
the user g is for members of the group
o is for others and a is for all of
those
then we have a minus sign a plus sign or
an equal sign
so a minus sign will remove a permission
a plus sign we'll add a permission we'll
come back to equals and then finally the
permission that we're trying to change
read writer x execute
so let me just show an example to make
it a little clearer here if we have g
plus w
what we're saying here is four members
of the group
add so plus
the right permission
so here's what it looked like before for
group r dash dash after we run this it's
now r
w dash so we added that w there but only
for the group
here's another example
here we have that right permission for
uh owner and for group
we have an a and that means all so
everyone all three of these chunks
minus remove the w the right permission
so we go from having right here and a
right here to now having no right
permission no right permission and no
write permission
so let's show an example
why don't i go back to my home directory
as colt
and
let's see i've got this permissions
folder inside of it i have only colt
coltscanread.txt why don't i change it
so that
how about
everyone so all of us can read the
contents of this file
so it's not going to have a great name
anymore it will still be only colt can
read but that's not going to be true
so this is what it looks like at the
moment i'm going to run chamod change
mode
and then i'm going to say everyone so a
all
i want to add the read permission
so add the read permission for everyone
and then the file
ls-l
we now see everybody has an r
so this means as you know if i go back
to being elvis
i can read the contents of that file now
whoops only
why don't i see it here
oh jeez because elvis does not have
permission
to
do anything in this directory remember
if we back out one level
here we are this permissions directory
we can see
there is no read
attribute present so elvis can even list
the contents of that folder so why don't
we add that r back in with what we know
what i want to do is change mode and i'm
going to switch back to being colt
change mode
and what i'm going to do is change it
for other
so that's what the o if i go back here
o means the world or others anybody
who's not the owner or part of the group
so here's permissions here everyone
already has an r
group
the actual owner but i want to add this
r back in so i'm going to say for others
plus r add the read attributes
for the permissions
folder oh i'm in the permissions folder
oh come on
i gotta back out
okay let's try that again for others add
the read permission to the permissions
directory here it is right now i'm gonna
hit enter ls-l
and now what do we see on permissions
there is an r present that means if i go
back to being elvis
i can now cd into permissions
and finally i can read the contents of
only colt can read because now we have
permission to read both that file and
the parent directory
now go back to being colts
and what i'm going to do next is show
let's see how to revoke permission so we
use the minus sign
so i'll revoke let's go back to um
well let's go back into permissions
here's that one file i'm going to revoke
the read permission for everyone except
for me
so i'm going to do that here so i'm
going to do
change mode why don't i revoke it for
the group first to show that so i'm
going to say
group g
minus
r
for the group members of the group
remove or revoke the read permission on
only cult can read
and now you'll see there's no r present
here
i could do the same thing but remove it
for
others
ls-l
we can see it's now gone
now i can also do multiple at once so if
i did this o minus rwx this means others
remove read write and execute
permissions
so if i want to add
how about full permissions read write
and execute for everyone i could do
chamod
and then for everyone all i want to add
read write execute
on only can read
and there we are our wx our wx rwx
so it's now executable it's showing up
differently
it isn't actually going to do anything
if i execute it because
well it's not a script just a text file
but anyway that's kind of the basics if
i wanted to remove execute permissions
for everyone you know i could do jamaad
all minus x
and now we we have rw dash rw dash rw
dash so that's a quick intro to using
chamod with this syntax now there's
actually another syntax that we can use
that is quite a bit more
intimidating when you're starting out
and i'm just going to alert you to his
existence we can use octal notation
which is base eight for these three
digits of binary
correspond to a file mode so zero zero
zero is going to be dash dash dash one
one one is rwx one zero zero is r dash
dash so that's the binary here but each
one of those in base eight is a single
digit zero through seven
it can be a little complicated to
understand but as you can see here if
you saw chamod seven five five what that
tells us is for that first chunk
seven
is one one one meaning rwx
five is one oh one right it's binary uh
three binary digits is a single octal
digit anyway our r dash x is what we end
up with there
i know it's kind of confusing it really
is trust me if i have to teach this uh
but there are some modes that are more
common and you'll get used to them if
you encounter them but you can always
use the longer sort of englishy syntax
that looks like this you know with the
letters and plus or minus
rather than having to worry about base 8
craziness
but that is something you'll see
now what about the equal sign
i said i'd come back to this the equal
sign
is basically a way of saying in this
example a equals r
set for all
set it to be
only read permissions and nothing else
so it it's going to reset every other
value so let's see an example of this in
action we just have this only can read
file which is actually not accurate
but if i do want to make let's say
i want to
i don't know
i'm grasping at straws here uh i'll make
it so everyone can read and only read so
no write permissions no execute
what i can do is jamaad everybody all
now instead of doing plus read or minus
w because minus w would subtract right
except get rid of that get rid of that
but if i do equals
read what this says is that
the only permissions that we're having
ignore everything else and get rid of
them is read for everyone for all
so ls-l
and there we go everyone can read
but nothing else if i instead if i just
did a equals
i can also do multiple like rw
or rwx that's a long way but i can give
everybody permissions and then if i went
back and re-ran this so that it's
equals r
again that means only read get rid of
everything else so we'll go from rwx rwx
rwx to instead
rr and just dashes for the read and
write permissions
all right so i know this is a pretty
complicated topic uh there's a lot to
cha mod
not to mention just pronouncing it
oh i guess i did not show we can also
change permissions for multiple who at
whose at one time
so if i wanted to
add write permissions only for the owner
and the group owner i could do this
chamod
so the owner is you the group owner is g
and then plus w
for right
and now we can see the owner and the
group owner has that w there so we can
have multiple values on the left hand
side of that whatever plus minus equals
and then again we have the octal
notation which you'll see um you know
777 means rwx for everyone full
permissions uh and you can spend more
time learning this if you really care
about it it is something you'll see in
the wild but for now all i care about is
that you understand the basic concept of
these permissions and all these
different different letters here rwx and
dashes what does that mean what is the
significance
and then remember if we go back we
talked about the owner and how we can
change a file's owner using tone
we can also use it to change the group
that owns a file
and then we can change individual
attributes using chamod change mode
that's a lot
well we made it to the end we covered a
ton of different commands maybe it's a
little bit overwhelming maybe you're a
little tired of seeing all the scrolling
text go by
but remember the point of all this is
not to memorize and just become an
expert on every single command overnight
what really matters is being able to put
the different pieces together to use the
correct command when you need it read
the man pages figure out how something
works change what options you're using
and just kind of duct tape it together
when needed obviously some of these
commands become second nature
lscd touch make directory rm that sort
of thing
you get pretty comfortable using
different expansions and redirection and
piping and combining different commands
but then some of these more niche
commands certainly i wouldn't expect you
to just remember and and honestly in
preparing this sort of course i always
have to look at the man pages and remind
myself of all the different options and
how they work so thanks again for
joining me and remember if you are
interested in my bootcamp you can find
the link in the description and lastly
thanks again to flavio
for the excellent handbook
all right well it was nice uh i guess
recording this in a dark room and
editing it in an equally dark room
uploading it to youtube
and
being alone in this whole process
but honestly who needs friends or
companionship
when you have the most sensual command
man touch
that's really all i need okay i gotta go
get my cat to the vet